you've found yourself at the junction
where worlds meet
politics civility how about honesty in
this country folks entertainment i don't
like entertainment and a whole bunch of
other stuff
it's about having a healthy body image
you have a very unhealthy body you
should have a horrible body in it not a
big home improvement market
we are definitely going to get letters
you're listening to talk radio's
strangest animals
glad to be with you we are working now
hopefully everyone can hear me
we did this on the live stream uh online
before now we are live with you of
course thank you not gay jared will be
fired after the break uh
i am your host stephen kreider producing
with me in studio as always is not gay
jared but a lot of with crowder.com
follow him at not gay jared he is not
gay i fulfill my legal obligations draw
your own conclusions i'm assuming that
we're good i don't need to afford you
that luxury today
since you've screwed up so badly big
guests today for those who don't know we
have actually i'm under the impression
his exclusive interview the first
interview with curt schilling of espn
after the debacle of him posting posted
an image of [ __ ]
with this whole north carolina situation
was fired from this round two for him by
the way this is round two of the meme
like backlash they had something this
last year with an islam meme but he
wasn't fired wasn't fired i don't think
but i mean this is like so this is
around rondo this is probably getting
two he's a repeat offender yeah he is so
he's going to be on here in the third
hour he's going to phone in and uh uh i
i had no idea that he was following me i
guess a fan of the show we're incredibly
grateful we have an exclusive on that we
have gavin mcinnis always fun we'll be
playing new as gender pronoun and we
have dave rubin lovely uh comedian host
uh more left and uh always fun to have
him on so great guests lined up today
and a big show a lot going on this week
big show like online did you uh
do did you hear that prince died and he
just got in
you are an absolute [ __ ]
it is mind-numbing no that's here do i
know that prince died yes like that's a
horrible way to introduce it the singer
on air yes it's been trending everywhere
i don't how could i not know i know i
just what you just said
is one of the most insanely idiotic
things i have ever heard
thank you but seriously i mean i figured
since you were traveling you may not
have i was traveling i was doing a show
now people talking about no point
in your rambling incoherent response
were you even close to anything
that could be considered a rational
thought
i just wondered if you knew about it
it's an interesting topic
people are talking about it yeah there's
also an election going on i don't know
if you wanted to notify our audience to
that too yes
sex can result in pregnancy everyone in
this room
is now dumber for having listened to it
you just queued me up with it perfectly
and then i award you no points
and may god have mercy on your soul
prince did pass away he did we are aware
of this i was aware of this i you know
listen i didn't listen to prince a whole
lot
uh i think of batman
vicky vale right yeah that's true that's
what i think of yeah well that's because
you're you're um you're a horrible human
being and you don't actually recognize
his true accomplishments the guy was a
wildly talented musician taught himself
like how many instruments yeah and you
know it was overshadowed by the gimmick
that's one of those things that happens
with a lot of these people and you see
it you see it with in any form of media
you see it with comedians you see it
with musicians they're brilliant kind of
like lady gaga lady gaga was a great
jazz musician if you actually look and
see she had to go weird to make it well
you know ugly chicks have to go fishing
with dynamite and so if people aren't
showing up for your jazz recital you
toss on a meat suit and expose your
nipples and call it a day
um not that not
my point is there's she's talented
prince was incredibly talented and i
feel like prince is one of those artists
a lot of people want to say they like
prince
but didn't really listen to him and i'm
just honest i had heard a couple of you
know a couple of his main songs um so i
don't want to pretend like i'm a fan a
lot of people do that like when someone
says oh i can't believe it
oh china the wrestler died isn't this
and it's like it's sad if someone dies
but i'm not gonna i wasn't a fan i
didn't follow the wwe divas i won't lie
there was a part of me
that thought prince was dead already
there i said it
my outside thoughts
inside thoughts are now out well that
you should keep them as inside thoughts
speaking of innies inside outside uh
donald trump this week we'll go right
into this because we'll no doubt have to
get into this with guests um we've
talked about this we did the transgender
bill schoolhouse rock parody on there
for those who don't know bruce
springsteen
uh brian adams all these people are
boycotting north carolina over the
trends lgbtq aaip bathroom laws
basically the bathroom laws for those
who haven't been following it if you've
been living under a rock uh it's another
it's why kurt schilling was fired so
conservatives were obviously
opposed not only conservatives moderate
leftists were saying this is getting a
little absurd okay if businesses want
people
who have penises to use the men's room
they should have this is not an entirely
right issue this isn't right versus left
most people agree with that
um and that's why there was this outrage
that kurt schilling was fired
but now there's donald trump today so
let's talk about this let's roll you the
clip let's roll the clipper don't got an
issue here mr trump please be specific
tell us your views on lgbt how you plan
to be inclusive as president speak about
north korea bathroom law in particular
oh i had a feeling that question was
going to come up i will tell you well
north carolina did something was very
strong and they're paying a big price
and there's a lot of problems and i
heard one of the best answers i heard
was from a commentator yesterday saying
leave it the way it is right now there
have been not very few problems just
displayed no idea north carolina what
they're going through with all of the
business that's leaving and all of the
strife and and that's on both sides you
leave it the way it is there have been
very few complaints the way it is people
go they use the bathroom that they feel
is appropriate there has been so little
trouble and the problem with what
happened in north carolina is the strife
and the the economics he goes on he
repeats himself we can just we don't
have to watch the whole thing and he
goes on to say that transgender people
should be able to use whatever bathroom
they want um okay so for those this is
this is important right you can't again
if you just say i don't care about any
of it i want donald trump sorry let's
just lay into this here you cannot on
what we're thirs yeah you cannot on
wednesday night
be outraged and it's the number one
trend and i've watched all of these
trump people you cannot be outraged that
kurt schilling was fired for clearly
speaking out against the transgender law
even people like like james woods and
celebrities you cannot be outraged and
point out how silly it is and then
justify these remarks into the mental
gymnastics the next day to say well no
it's okay for trump to say that first
off some people are trying to say here
well you know why let me tell you why if
you believe he's politically incorrect
he's going to this is the most spineless
politically correct statist answer you
could possibly give not only has he
displayed that he has no understanding
of how state laws work or why this law
was created in the first place he's not
an intelligent man he doesn't know
listen he doesn't know he doesn't
there's the combination of him not being
very bright in understanding how
government works and he's now going to
turn go back to the previous episodes
like i said in the general election
he's going to be far more gentle on
hillary clinton than he's been on
republicans watch if he makes it through
he probably won't make it through if it
goes to a second ballot but
let's assume that he does let's assume
that he gets the the delegates um
this is the pc appeasing the left answer
expect this in a general so there's that
there's a politically correct we know
he's not willing to be politically
incorrect when it's hard this is an
issue he's caved okay
you can't leave the laws the way they
are
this gets into why is he an
authoritarian status the reason north
carolina had to create this law was
because of a city ordinance in charlotte
by the way donald trump i'm sure knows
this if you're a landlord in new york
city you can be fined for using the
proper gender pronouns remember we
covered that yep yep if you own a
building in new york city you're like oh
oh
dick's in the bathroom and you know you
go in the ladies room if you do that you
can be fined and what does that really
mean you can lose your business you can
be sued this happens in new york city
another reason why new york values suck
oh but i'm from new york yeah your
values suck
if the values of a city involve finding
somebody for recognizing
biology
the values of that city suck
so that's what happened we know that's
happened in new york that's what
happened with charlotte basically
forcing you know forcing these places
businesses to say no you have to let
people use whatever bathroom they feel
like so the state came in and said no
use the bathroom that you were born with
let's simplify the confusion
and people can talk about religious
protection we've talked about this last
week they train lions that it
discriminates against gay people it has
nothing to do with gay people it has to
do specifically with businesses churches
organizations having the right to say
listen you've got a john thomas
don't go in the girls room and it was
necessary because of charlotte the law
was created in response to encroaching
government power
okay that's why so you can't leave it
the way it is you don't know what you're
talking about
and of course you don't know what you're
talking about and you're trying to use
it to appease a politically correct left
if you were protesting kurt schilling
being fired on espn on wednesday and
then doing mental loop-de-loops to
justify trump's remarks the next day
come on just say you don't care i have
no problem with people who don't care
but when i you can see the timelines
right oh this is ridiculous men
shouldn't be in the girls restroom this
is ridiculous i support north carolina
i'm going to boycott bruce springsteen
then this trump thing comes up well you
know what maybe it doesn't matter anyway
let's talk about the economy
my only request is that you did it
i i match your cop out with another cop
house
i see your cop out i raise you another
no he played devil's advocate we got
like two minutes
what do you think maybe you're not
prepared for this
uh tennessee i believe it is the
governor republican
pressuring businesses with tax hikes if
they don't support the law there's one
for you i mean if they don't support
the same kind of bill that is being
passed in north carolina the same h1 how
do you how do you pressure them i don't
know
what tax tax if they don't get so you
so you say okay or honor the bill i'm
not
sure you say hey i don't know um queer
burger
you're going to let people use whatever
restrooms they want we're going to tax
you more no no he's for the bill he
wants the transgender bill so that like
north carolina has passed right so he
wants it to be bathroom on your
biological yes but my point is so let's
say a private business like i don't know
queer burger or whatever it is gay
burger says hey we want to let anyone
use whatever bathroom this governor
wants to tax that business more i think
so i think that's that's the gist i got
well if it's a gist you got i would need
to read up on it more um my initial
reaction would be disagree and if i
haven't read up on i've been on the road
performing so if this just happened
recently but i would have to read up on
it um my issue would be if it's
businesses lobbying against it trying to
force other businesses to recognize any
kind of a bathroom but you know this
isn't just businesses it also goes to
public buildings you know that's what
you have in these other states too so in
public buildings um i do think it should
be left to businesses
i think that just like i think bed and
breakfast should have the right to say i
don't want to marry two guys named ted
go to another one or they don't have to
bake a cake with two wieners on it so
yeah i would at first glance be against
that law oh we have to go we'll come
back and fight about this
more fighting
in fact
and now for sean king claims things well
all right mr king i am so glad that we
have that saga behind us we can just
move forward on a purely professional
basis um yes
me too as well great now of course
you're aware that um there have been
accusations that you've plagiarized this
recent article of yours is this
in fact just shoot me straight is this
your article yes
that is
my article okay so i just want to be
clear for the record you are in fact
claiming that this is an original piece
of content from you yeah
that is correct
okay so people claiming that it came
from this other publication that uh
there's no basis i wrote that as well
i'm sorry what do you mean from the
other
publications you just said it was
original that it wasn't in another
publication
yes but i did it
let me ask you something did you make
this computer yes i did in fact make
that personal computer
mr king are you just claiming things
yes what about these pants i'm wearing
did you make these pants yes you sewed
them stitched them yes i did
manufactured them yes and distributed
them
yeah did you carry it to the store and
uh place a sales tag on it yes what
about the liquidation stickers did you
put those in the pants yes that is my
sticker these glasses did you make these
glasses yes you are claiming that these
glasses right here on my head you made
them yes i am claiming those glasses
your complete and utter lack of regard
for the truth is is nothing short of
remarkable i've been told that before
that's been this week's installment of
sean king claims things
all right glad we were dancing the
studio i was pushing my cleavage
together because you know what i'm going
this thursday is practically the weekend
i'm going to be that's why android don't
say what date is we have some of our
wonderful affiliates who run it not
necessarily on thursday
well people can build
new hampshire
northern florida patriot voices northern
michigan uh klid missouri wham cohn
alaska wkmq missouri a few more that i'm
missing you didn't memorize as you're
reading this i am reading those those
are right in front of me i have my
cholesterol numbers right below them
on my notes for today i don't know why
those are there
uh how is it by the way is it good
fantastic that's great
my my uh my cholesterol numbers are
fantastic and they got way better when i
started eating more meat and fat i gotta
break it i wasn't actually interested no
okay
well that's reasonable not gay jared
that's absolutely reasonable we have a
few stories you know i was let me let me
start with this here
we have reuben coming up after the break
dave rubin i was uh performing it at
bucknell university and uh you know i'm
great it was one of those things the
date got mixed the venue got mixed so it
was a middle of the road show but uh tom
over there who hosted it he he uh
produces milo's podcast great guy nice
guy
um we did this this show sort of started
out as stand up and then i blew up my
knee doing my penguin impression and i
just happened to the best of us i just
forgotten my whole set list because it
was just blinding pain but we did a q a
with the audience
and a few things that were remarkable
with the audience for those listening
people who listen to this tend to be
relatively educated they tend to be in
the know they're pretty engaged if
you're listening to this show typically
you know more than the average citizen
regarding politics there was there were
some protesters there were some people
who showed up some leftists who were
there to not laugh so when we started
talking uh having a discussion asking
questions
the first question i always ask is what
is the fundamental role of government
and no leftist has ever answered this at
a program and of course the
conservatives answer it it's to protect
the inalienable rights of the people and
then the left will go leftist well which
rights well isn't it great that we have
the constitution as a blueprint
this one guy who was a bernie sanders
supporter saying isn't the government's
job to represent the most amount of
people i said no
he said uh i really want them to
redistribute wealth and i think that's
because it needs to be what's better for
people i said you need to substantiate
that he wasn't able to and i asked him
well okay you want to what do you
believe he said fairness what about
something like a flat tax
he said well no that's not fair this is
true by the way and you can ask tom over
there young america for liberty
you could feel the wave over the room of
conservatives realizing that the
leftists who are professional protesters
who tried to ban milo from campus who
weren't happy that i was showing up on
campus they had no idea what
conservatives were thinking this really
happened in real time and i think it's
important for you to hear this
he said no because that would hurt the
poor more because they end up paying and
the rich don't pay anything i said it
seems to me you have a problem with the
general uh concept of percentages
he said what do you mean if i make a
hundred thousand dollars and i pay
twenty thousand dollars
and then i make a million dollars and i
pay 200 000
how is that not fair
he said oh
oh that's a flat tax i said yeah what
did you think it was i thought it was
like a flat fee that everyone paid
i said okay so what i just described to
you is that fair
well it's more fair than i thought
and i said yeah but you already voted
you
absolute butthole
at this point he had already voted for
bernie sanders and he was like well no
it's their duty to vote i said it's not
no it's not a virtue for you to go out
and vote you don't even know what what a
flat tax is you have no idea what this
is you're welcome you never stop to
think about how those numbers didn't
work no he never stopped i thought think
that oh there's no way a poor person
could pay
say
dollars it never occurred to him and no
no no no one corrected him from the left
there was a whole group of people more
leftist not a single one knew they
probably didn't know either no they
didn't know the only people who spoke up
were the con republicans conservatives
saying no that's not a flat tax and then
he was willing to reconsider it same
thing we had women who were talking
about feminism on campus and they
believed in safe spaces they could not
name one single right afforded to men
that weren't afforded to women in 2016.
and we ended up having a dialogue and
afterward they came up and they thanked
me and they said hey you know we
appreciate you at least letting us you
know speak a lot of conservative
speakers come here with with cue cards
they don't actually answer any questions
so and actually that's something a lot
of people do al franken does that where
he goes with cue cards from the audience
i used to know a stand-up comedian who
would do that he'd be like hey i'm going
to do some improv comedy cute and the
cue card was always like kiana reeves
making a pizza and he was doing it no
way making a pizza like kiana reeves and
everyone who's seen his act like okay
improv we get it so we actually had a
dialogue with these kids and you will
you will be sometimes astounded as to
the very doesn't mean they're stupid but
the very basic ideas uh of which they've
never really thought and afterwards
something that struck me
this is why we do this program we have
very smart people on this program you
know ruben's a smart guy we've had get
set on we have we have uh
molecular biologists how many degrees
does gerald have these days i don't know
how many he has i've lost track um we've
had psychiatrists who lecture across the
country and then we also play spot the
training we have all kinds of silly
stuff as well but
if it seems like something like this if
you think it's well why is that
reductive when you have a significant
portion of kids in college who are
getting master's degrees who don't know
what a flat tax is it's important these
kids couldn't name the three branches of
government
that's why schoolhouse rock i'm such a
big advocate you could learn the
preamble of the constitution the three
roles of three branches of government
what their role is how a bill becomes a
law
and your conjunctions and you can learn
it in the span of an afternoon
kids aren't getting a basic education on
college campus afterwards this girl came
up who was all about you know police
brutality and feminism and safe spaces
she said well thank you for for at least
listening should you know i've never
heard your opin the opinions you you
spouse before so i wasn't ready for it i
said i said thank you i said i
appreciate that but let me bring
something up to you i said every single
conservative here in this audience has
heard all of your opinions
every opinion you express tonight
they've heard it before
i didn't even really have to answer
these questions i just happen to have
the microphone i said you know why
because
it's the same opinion of all your
professors and they've had to defend it
their entire life they've heard nothing
but your opinions
everything you've expressed they've
heard multiple times and have been able
to substantiate why they disagree with
it you have not even heard one opinion
that i expressed tonight i said if you
want to talk about diversity who do you
think is surrounding themselves with a
more intellectually diverse group he
said you know what that's that's true i
really should educate myself i should
learn more she had never heard anybody
say the wage gap is a myth
just didn't believe me this girl
tom who's listening there from bucknell
people were astounded
when i talked about statistics
brought up police brutality i said well
if we talk about you know police
shootings with with young black children
actually you're more likely to be shot
as a young white person i don't believe
you i said okay let's give you as much
leeway as possible and me as little as
possible that's how we try and frame
these debates let's say that's not true
so could we at least acknowledge that
statistically black americans commit
more crimes that it would probably
correlate the arrests or cops shooting
them would correlate if if not in an
inverse correlation compared to white
people with their violent crime rate and
she said well i don't know where those
statistics should i don't really know
what statistics are anyway what are they
really you could they can just say
anything i said no statistics are a
they're a numerical equation that is
statistic that is
verifiable that you can observe that is
used to to
estimate correlation and causation it's
not an opinion it's not a feeling it's
not a safe space that's what statistics
are
well i don't agree i disagree actually i
disagree
this is what's happening on college
campuses
and sometimes we start off we'll get
into a lot today but it can get nerdy
you need to realize some people don't
even have a basic understanding of
government or know what a flat tax is
dave rubin after the break he's one of
the smart ones stay tuned
whoa jared what are you doing shoot
megan with what my ar-15 where'd you get
it ar-15.com oh there's another one
you got em thank god for ar15.com they
have ar-15 and accessories for sale and
the best advice there is on the web oh
no there's another one
that's the best place to go and that's
the takeaway because this commercial's
about to stop
this week and not gay jared's diet
habits
what what is that is that an energy
drink yeah
what is that next to it
some skittles
what did you have for dinner
the first half of the skittles you know
your body can't be healthy
right
i assume so
it's not possible to be healthy eating
like that
oh
well
i had an apple earlier
stay tuned for more of not gay jared's
diet habits
all right we are glad to bring on our
first guest i don't know if i'd use the
word glad but uh you can see his show on
he's already laughing before he even
bring him he doesn't understand the
rules of broadcasting this hack
youtube.com
reuben
ruben report you can watch it all over
itunes aura tv dave rubin thanks for
being on sir
crowder i love this you were just on my
show we're doing an old school cross
promotion right now this is this is very
professional man sponsored by the
colgate hour
um
which is funny we're kind of going back
to that have you noticed that we went
from like all you know ad breaks with a
ton of ads and now it's going back to
sponsored content like the full program
has one or two main sponsors it's
everything old is new again
everything old is new you know sponsored
content as long as they're not telling
you what to say
it's pretty good because you know
there's there's some products that i
wouldn't mind having a nice red wine
bottle behind me and talking about how
i'm drinking it i don't have one behind
me at the moment but i think that would
be pretty sweet well one of our sponsors
is simplifiedwine.com so you should do
that they just they ship wine to your
door you call you're like i like this
pinot this is my budget and then he
curates it and sends it to you what what
if i steal them from you right now you
can steal him he doesn't really have any
money
so he pays me in swill and it's like
you're doing this for money yeah i know
what it would you know sell out that's
kind of that's kind of the conundrum so
okay we were just talking about this on
your show people talk about media and
sort of being corporate you know
corporate sellouts um i've always been
open on this channel we have a very
select few sponsors every now and then
we just make money on whatever the
general ad revenue is um but yeah i want
to pay not gay jared and our employees
well
i want to grow and increase influence
at what point do you think that crosses
over into when does it become a problem
well you know look it's different it's
different for everybody and if you have
integrity which i think you do and i
think i do it makes it trickier right
right no integrity there you're faking
it pretty i fake it pretty well yeah
it's uh it's all a sham i got the coke
brother money in back yeah you do a nice
job with that i'm still trying to get
that uh the big fracking money that you
mentioned fracking yes i want i want
burn slant oil drilling money remember
that from the simpsons oh yeah that's
right that's slant drilling it was
pretty brilliant that's what caused the
who shot mr burns episode anyway um wow
that's right yeah i didn't realize
you're such a simpsons trivia guy sorry
oh almost everything i know from comedy
is from seasons like four to eight those
those prime years of simpsons oh yeah i
love it um
well actually i watched the simpsons
this past sunday season 27
uh it was an episode like all about apu
and the kwik-e-mart and i laughed a
couple times and i was like all right
that's the best they can do now but it's
pleasant because you know what usually
i'm watching tv and i'm like oh this is
all horse garbage uh so you know if i
can laugh twice in a half hour don't
don't uh this is actually out on fcc uh
radio so don't uh don't make not gay
jared's job harder sorry that's okay no
you're right you know i have a good
friend actually who does a lot of voices
in the simpsons and she's a she's a
conservative and she talked about how
hostile it is there just when they're in
there recording how nobody else is in
the entertainment industry and she has
to keep it a secret and you would know
her right away she's one of the
prominent um voice actresses on there
but uh yeah it was a great show they
tried to be family guy for a while
remember because they were losing steam
and family guy came in and you could
sort of see it seeping into the
influence and you're like it doesn't
work don't try and be family guy b
simpsons kind of like you know dave dave
be dave rubin don't be um
i don't know who else i don't know
you're dave rubin i don't know don't
don't don't be uh don't be larry king
you know because now you're working with
him insert other generic gay guy
or not gay guy
yeah or not i'm not very good at the gay
thing i'm good from like 10 p.m
to
like one at one am those are my like
main gay hours anyway let's claim i'm
the best
i don't want to brag question uh what
point does it become a problem you know
people talk about mainstream media and
corporate media right but everyone has
to make a living so at what point is it
genuinely a problem or someone's not
being honest
yeah well look i i have a great
situation here with aura because as i
told you a couple minutes ago on my show
uh they let me do whatever i want and
i'm obviously salaried by them uh but
their goal they they have never pulled
me aside and say this say that i
honestly a hundred percent honestly i
don't even know the executives that are
in this building right now i don't even
know their political opinions on
anything truly uh and that's a beautiful
thing because it allows me to go about
my own
business in a way where i'm only
beholden to my thoughts that that's
pretty certain such a contrast when i
was with traditional media oh my gosh i
was always getting into trouble
right so
so that's you know look that's why
people don't trust mainstream media
anymore you know right this very second
i do have my turn in the right way i've
got an ifb in and that's just so i can
hear you but i don't have anyone in the
control room barking orders at me or i
hope they're not going to maybe they'll
start right now but you know what i mean
because of that we can just do this
freely this is the beauty of the
internet and that's why we have to make
sure that as we've seen some of the the
screws tightening on the internet you
know where we know shadow banning is
going on on twitter and you've you
always tweet every now and again you'll
say subscribe to my show before they
kick me off twitter right you know we've
been worse with facebook we're actually
in litigation right now with facebook
because they
it's not just they censored us they did
something wrong financially were they we
can't get into all of it on air but it
is right now they are apologizing and
trying to remedy it and yeah this kind
of stuff happens a lot and a lot of
people don't have the power to stand up
to it um and uh you know it is generally
anti anti-conservative and that's
because they see the conservatives as
the radical free speech people and the
hate speech and so you're sort of i
guess an un
uh unwilling brother in arms like you
pulled into it
that that's a good way to describe it i
mean that that's sort of how i feel
because we can we can disagree about as
much political stuff as you want to get
into um but i absolutely more than
anything else believe in free speech you
can say absolutely
whatever you want short short of direct
call for violence direct call for murder
and and harming someone but short of
that you can say whatever you want and i
will
counter your speech with speech i will
not silence you i will not stop you know
a couple weeks ago they had these people
these trump people wanted to get to a
rally in arizona and there were bernie
people that were literally blocking the
highway that's not you know we have a
social contract that we should allow
each other to speak and then beat their
speech you got a better idea let's have
a battle of ideas if you don't let
people have the battle of ideas then
actually you just strengthen a lot of
the other side i know you're not a big
trump guy but a lot of the reason that
the trump stuff is working is because
his people feel that they can't get
their message out now that may not be
true at all
no but i understand i agree with it and
then like so and i've defended that you
know i've written about that multiple
times and defended it
like in chicago in the bernie rally but
like you said you go well what you have
to get to about what is not defensible
is a direct call to action and i'm going
okay you're getting into territory where
it's punch them in the face and i'll pay
your legal fees
you know then all of a sudden shanks
like you can't you'll fire at a crowded
theater i'm like well if someone's
absurd no one's arguing that but then
you have some people who are arguing you
can offer to pay someone's legal fees if
they punch them in the face we're
getting into indefensible territory and
that's my issue with like hey it doesn't
have to go this you can still make a
valid argument and and not go full crazy
well this is where everyone except for
this little sliver i think somewhere in
the middle between classic liberals and
libertarians has gone completely bonkers
so of course you're right trump is
inciting violence when he implies that
if someone punches someone he's going to
pay for the legal fees and then someone
get punched right so we have somewhat of
a connection there right now at the same
time
the day of the of the trump rally in
chicago it wasn't the trump people that
were outside uh attacking cops and
burning things and breaking windows
right those those were bernie people so
both sides are at fault here and look i
don't think bernie himself is
instigating people to violence but there
is something behind the social justice
uh movement that is allowing people to
think that violence what's very simple
is okay it's very simple that's the
problem yeah and this is what i say and
you may disagree um but when you call
someone a racist when you call someone a
sexist and a homophobe and a fascist and
a transphobe you've now made them out to
be worse than nazis would any of us
disagree that if a nazi walked on in who
wanted to actually kill jews
that it would be acceptable to jail that
person of course not we all would have a
problem with nazis but when you create
when you treat someone when you make
them out to be less than human you make
it acceptable to treat them in a way
that's subhuman and that's what you're
seeing and it started with tea parties
racist and now everything is sexist
homophobic transphobic they think if you
have a a penis that you should use the
male's locker room bruce springsteen and
pearl jam think they need to protest the
state because that's hate speech
equivalent to lynch mobs and i'm going
to get for talking to oh sorry not that
i'm going to get stuff for uh just
talking to a straight white male you're
the worst you're the worst of the worst
yeah i know well you're yeah you're a
white you're a white male just you know
he likes to party you know what actually
even the gay thing right now these are
being shifted out of the pecking order
you know this pecking order that the
left has with this stuff gay men and
especially gay white men are really
being pushed out of that now we're
viewed as privileged so they they're
they're sort of done with us too which
is which is obviously a problem well
because also gay white men tend to be
very successful i mean you up you tend
to uh fill that into the bell curve with
tend to be smarter tend to be creative
um it's one of those things milo talked
about it you know it's just people may
not like hearing this it's just a
statistic gay men tend to be relatively
smart for whatever reason good looking
and successful therefore you must hate
those people because they're successful
is that how it works i think that's how
it works on the left i just don't i just
don't like you because you're gay so you
know that started off that way
what what just happened why are you
looking around oh we froze there oh you
froze it's not good
oh we're good we can see you you're fine
it must be
tell aura to spring for high speed there
dave reuben uh it happened right at time
i said i don't like you because you're
gay punchline and he's looking around
like people people are gonna go oh no he
really offended him how do i run
i knew you couldn't be talking about me
that's why so i'm looking at my people
though you can't be talking about me i
was talking to the gay intern no but
that's that's my point right as they
just so for us it's been so much further
behind you on the trail where we've been
condemned and now you're experiencing it
let me ask you this where do you feel
when they just toss it all in you know
like a good example north carolina right
they go the
anti-lgbtq laws first off i think anyone
who use lgbtq seriously should be
roasted with their own thanksgiving
turkey with a steak of holly driven
through their heart joe there's a guy in
there now there's another it's lgbtq a
ip but lgbtq is widely accepted even
joel mchale went up i remember his stand
up was he just said he's like what the f
north carolina what the f i want to give
all my money to the lgbtq community
without a sense of this is kind of
ridiculous how do you feel being the g
this is entirely by the way bathroom
situation it has nothing to do with gay
people at all um
how do you feel with that where they
just lump you in with that same moniker
well i'm glad you made that distinction
first because i've said this many times
that being being a gay male or being a
lesbian or something else you know we
put all these letters together but but
the truth is that i don't know
intrinsically more about the trans
experience than you do now it's an it's
an other right in in terms of sexuality
i suppose so that that's why these
people are grouped together and i i know
some trans people and i have uh some
good trans friends but
i but i don't i'm not inherently by
being gay right that doesn't make me
know anything more about their
experience but but this without getting
into the minutia of this specific law
because we know these things come and
then you know two months later they're
they're forgotten about um but it is so
directly linked to what you said before
about the the everyone's racist
homophobe sexist every other thing right
um and that's why i'm really proud if
i've done anything since we started this
show in september that i've really
helped
normalize and get to to the mainstream
this regressive left
phrase because these people they are
pretending to be progressives they are
pretending to be for progress and yet
what they are for really is regression
they are for viewing us all only by the
color of our skin or by our sexuality
or ironically by our religion even
though progressives are the supposedly
the most against religion there is right
uh and i say this as an atheist so
um so there's a lot there and that's why
i want people to
i know you've been fighting the good
fight on on your side for the right and
i know you want the the republican party
and the right to get back to some decent
ideals and have that battle of ideas and
that's why i'm doing it on the left can
we have you for one more shorter segment
can we do that
okay all right uh youtube.com
ruben report you can watch him
everywhere we're going to talk more
about lgbtq aaip and a silent number two
louder with crowder stay tuned
this is breaking news on louder with
crowder i'm perry matheson we're taking
out the weakest new york primary to
governor john kasich as he makes his
last campaign stop at a chipotle mexican
cuisine
i can't tell you how glad i am to be
here among everyday americans who serve
not only delicious food but really join
us together in a positive fusion of
mexican
and american cuisine i'm also happy to
open up the floor for questions but not
too long i really want to dig into this
taco salad
yes you sir
no no no who let him in here
the public space
but still
are you just following me around
playing semi-sonic's closing time
pretty much
you don't have
and you don't have anything better to do
huh
i lost my job
a lot of americans lost their job that's
why i'm running for the highest office
in the land
in ohio
are you a governor well i don't think
that's really you suck
hey
i do not
i do not suck
you're a strange animal
that's what i know
all right he is a busy man so we have to
let him go we can't take him uh for too
long youtube.com ruben report dave rubin
thank you for being here we were talking
about this before the break yeah you
know i've been fighting this fight for a
long time on youtube really going back
to 2009 2006 if you count some
semi-political videos
and um it wasn't very popular back then
there were no dave rubins you know
everyone was a militant leftist atheist
because they were in the environment
they hated george bush and so everyone
who was conservative was racist
and uh and so i think my reputation
precedes me because a lot of those
people have sort of transitioned but
still begrudging like no but i still
hate that crowder guy where's nothing
i'm saying is any different um
so i think you you know i he drafted
back in there behind the flying v but
i'm glad to help you out and i'm glad
you're in the fault um i'm glad that i
can provide you with a little self
affirmation yes well you people you
didn't exist you did not exist um or at
least maybe you were under certain uh i
don't know certain contracts or
authority where maybe you couldn't but
people out there just didn't believe
existed
i will be 100 honest with you as i would
be with you all the time
i didn't have my awakening yet i mean it
really cracked in the last two years uh
so i was what i would now consider to be
far left and i my intentions were always
good and that's why uh the phrase you
know the road to hell is paved with good
intentions i think a lot of these people
have good intentions you know sometimes
you'll you'll throw out you'll say well
these leftists and there's this
implication that they're all like you
know just profoundly and intentionally
evil yes some of them are some of them
are evil i'll give you that much but but
a lot of them do think
that this social justice warrior stuff
that all of this stuff really is the
right road to take and that's why that's
why i've tried to make my show about
ideas because i don't i don't want to
demonize them to the point where i can't
talk to them i've been trying to show
people that there is a little bit of a
wider net here and that's why it's
working yeah i think i think you're
right um i you know i separated into and
i was writing a book about this a while
back maybe i'll finish it but all the
conservative publishers were like ah we
don't really do comedy and it's not
doomsday enough they said everything has
to be an obama doomsday book right now
where it doesn't sell this isn't like
the wake of obama blueprint and i think
killing whatever was there's so many
killing books um but it's separate
killings have has o'reilly done already
well eventually i think it'll lead to
killing o'reilly and then it'll spare us
all
i think of what happened is
there are two kinds of they're what i
call modern leftists or you call them
the regressive left and then just the
american idiots because green day is
american idiot right they went to the uk
to record their anti-american song and
people pump their fists yeah america
stocks and i remember seeing them in con
live in canada and bright eyes and they
would just come there and say i'm moving
to canada right and it was an easy
applause it was like as a comedian right
you're in hey hello lancaster
so they always come in bash bush um and
there are those people who lie the james
cameron's the uh the people out there
and in heads of media uh the sean penns
who are dishonest who are so vested in
the agenda they can't get off of it and
then i think there are a lot of people
like you said who just buy it there
aren't bad intentions but they believe
it and it's important to delineate
between the two but i think there are
far more people who are malicious and
dishonest than i wanted to believe for a
long time when you have barack obama
going up and talking about the pay gap
that we know is false we know anyone
with a just a basic uh intern who can do
statistics knows it's untrue that's a
president who's being dishonest to
forward an agenda and and that's i would
say my awakening where i always said i
don't want to attribute to collusion
what can be attributed to incompetence i
think there's a lot more collusion than
i once believed well you know it's funny
to me because if you think about the the
bernie campaign right you know he
relentlessly talks obviously money in
politics is the number one thing there's
no question and i you know i think
people on both sides of the aisle do
think that money in politics is a huge
problem but you know he also talks about
totally for citizens united but you can
continue
you are for citizens united absolutely
do you know why it started
don't have any idea why
people have no idea why do you know why
citizens united exist
because they wanted to ban an
anti-hillary clinton documentary
that's that's the court case they're
saying no you can't release this before
an election and it was going to be
banned they were going to say nope you
can't fund this this can't go out and so
these filmmakers fought it so they would
have the right to make an anti-hillary
clinton documentary that's the basis for
it and so they said no corporations have
the same rights as people they recognize
them as personhood so these filmmakers
could make an anti-hillary documentary
people need to read up on the history of
there needs to be corrections because of
that case but it's not overturning the
right of businesses to have a say in
politics
all right so be that as a man as i said
the road to hell is pay for good
intentions right had some good
intentions with the law then i'll give
you that um
but that doesn't mean that the the money
in politics isn't a problem but anyway
the point the point is that when when
bernie says this stuff money in politics
and he talks about all america's wars
and he talks about health care what he's
really saying is that barack obama has
been a horrible president right right
because look you can blame we can all
again spend the endless amount of time
blaming george bush for iraq and
nobody's defending the iraq war anymore
and guess what saddam hussein was a
pretty horrible guy doing some horrible
stuff and we didn't have youtube as
excessively back then to see all the
awful things he was doing and throwing
gays off roofs and you know the horrible
torture chambers and terror and gassing
the courage and all kinds of terrible
stuff but he loves raising bran crunch
so there's that
right but the point is that that if as
bernie is running on
saying all the american wars and our
health care system so screwed up and the
money in politics well
it's been a pretty left guy in the oval
office for the last seven years so obama
hasn't i guess what bernie's saying is
well obama hasn't done anything about
our wars there's still plenty of drone
strikes right i think i just read this
morning that we're sending 200 troops on
the ground back to iraq or something um
you know obviously our healthcare
obamacare didn't work out as well as
obama would have liked because then
bernie wouldn't be talking about it
right so there's an interesting
condemnation of the left by bernie that
i don't think people have quite woken up
to i think you're right now just
when i wrote about it i was saying well
who do you have to blame
obama had for the first several years he
could do whatever he wanted and he did
and the same reason people are upset
with republicans is they haven't stopped
any of it what obama's wanted he's
gotten done and they just want more done
they just want more control they want a
public option they want to keep moving
further and that's why i say if people
want to talk about
extremes i don't i think i am far less
extreme than certainly bernie or barack
obama i don't think it's far more
extreme to say okay hold on this
healthcare plan didn't work let's allow
people to opt out let's allow private
organizations you know exemptions let's
allow insurance across state lines
tort reform
one is a much more extreme position and
i think that's where people like you
have had uh an awakening um and i've
awakened listen like we've talked about
it's the click bait the issues right now
there's some dishonesty in the media on
the right and we both have a problem
with that and uh there aren't many
people out there doing what you're doing
so you know even though you're uh you're
off it's lovely man well it's not lily
when you're off in cabo with all your uh
i don't know what you guys do i'm
assuming it's like a folsom street fair
in the beach but
youtube i'm married we
literally laid on the beach my phone was
locked in a safe for nine days i don't
buy it for a second i don't buy for a
second i don't buy it for a second you
people are scandalous and uh and uh i
won't i won't have it on my program here
youtube youtube.com
dave rubin thank you so much brother and
uh stay tuned for more louder with
crowder
this week in not gay jared's diet habits
one of those cheez-its yeah did you want
some
are you dipping cheez-its in ranch
yes
after you did the energy drinking
skittles earlier yeah this is uh there's
no way for your body to be able
to function at anything
don't worry about it
uh
uh asparagus
stay tuned for more of not gay jared's
diet habits
glad to be
glad to be back did you not have the mic
on again we're in the second hour
why was that on then but yours was on
producing with me in studios always by
the way people watching the live video
stream people who comment they're always
off beat it's because there's a delay in
a live video stream so we're actually
dancing to the real song and they're
getting a couple seconds there you go
lying to them again about your rhythm
skills you're you're you just you don't
i don't have rhythm i don't i don't i
don't deny that i have no rhythm but uh
uh
speaking of rhythm getting back to the
rim of the show we have gavin mcinnis
at the the half hour the bottom of the
hour and then we have an exclusive with
kurt schilling yes got canned from espn
i don't think he minds us using that
terminology
so a lot has been going on this week by
the way tweet me at s crowder what do
you think
i want to know
really from people who are trump
supporters we have people who who follow
this program uh it's no secret that i'm
not a big fan
where do you line up with the guy's
comments on the trans bathroom laws and
where did you line up with curt
schilling
do you feel that your position is
consistent
i would like i would like to hear that
so a couple of things we're going to
talk about have you heard about this
whole foods controversy i did i saw the
uh the pictures going up and i didn't
really know what was about so i did some
reading and it's pretty hilarious
actually it is pretty funny we have it
up on my screen here uh for those who
who didn't read it at the site you can
read it up at loudwrathcrowder.com so it
started out this horrible controversy
gay guy asks to have a wedding cake made
that says love wins
so there we go we can see it right there
and then he tweeted out i can't believe
whole foods and it says love wins [ __ ] on
the cake saying the baker
did a love wins calling him the f word
the the f word that we're not allowed
the cigarette the three letters yeah he
was referring to him as a cigarette um i
found himself i have to say f word i bet
you some stations are gonna we're not
gonna believe that it was on the cake it
said love wins [ __ ] so right away this
didn't pass the sniff test
because i'm okay i'm going okay this
just seems like an incredible liability
it's not really clever why would someone
do this from whole foods the hipster
bastion right the hamstrings
except for funny enough the guy's
actually libertarian when it comes to
the affordable care act well it's from
texas did you know that whole foods is
facing i've been to the the home the
first whole foods there in austin yeah
uh right near where lance armstrong had
has um had his bike and or testicle
steroids shop and it is uh it's very
nice it's very nice whole foods i don't
like whole foods my wife loves whole
foods i think it's overpriced and you
can go to the local farmers market
anyway that's not the point right away i
didn't pass a smell test but at this
point it already been trending hashtag
right social justice warriors all over
the place oh how dare you put this on a
cake
well
then we have security camera footage of
this gay man with the love wins cake
what are you doing not kj is like
fidgeting around the chair my chair is
all messed up and caught on the carpet
we're good we've got cart in the carpet
yeah we're good so
we now have the security footage which
which i have here up at the website
where he takes his cake looks at the
cake and walks out with that incident so
right away you're going well i you know
if i'm gay and i have the word [ __ ]
written across my cake i'll go hey i
want her love wins oh you wrote love
wins [ __ ] well that's one way to do
it just go back after the picture go
back it's like right dead center too
there's no missing it if you're walking
out with it actually there it is yeah
there's a picture right up on the screen
yeah there's no missing this
and if you're gay you don't see a cake
that says love wins [ __ ] you're like oh
ho that's one for you bye you know
you're upset
well the security camera footage the
camera footage at whole foods of this
purchase taking place reveals nothing of
the sort
so
not only did whole foods then whole
foods came out so this this didn't
happen this is not true
a hoax debunked faster than uh balloon
boy or clock boy yes or kate remember
the kid who put a clock in a suitcase
and he was like i'm a science engineer
yeah you and bill nye are scientists so
muhammad muhammad was that was it name
muhammad i thought
i think it was i think it was i don't
know i don't know he's in
qatar qatar how do you pronounce it i
always know
it's probably a different country now
it's been taken by somebody else
someone's been thrown off
with a lisp at some point
point is dave rubin's not visiting
anytime soon no
so this hoax is debunked and they say no
this didn't happen
um not only did it not happen the baker
who made the cake little wrinkle is also
gay
it came out like i wouldn't write that
i'm gay so this is entirely false it's
entirely fake manufactured just like we
have another story where a man was
suspended expelled from colorado state
university for not raping a woman he
didn't rape her the girl said that he
didn't rape her but a friend said that
he did rape her and so he was expelled
the ends justify the means with leftist
right it doesn't matter if it's true or
not and why do you have to make it the
right left because there is the right
left i was talking about this at the
college right when i was talking with
these students at bucknell
there's one group of people who want to
paint everyone as racist sexist
homophobic transphobic as a new thing
androgynous phobic
intersex phobic
they want to paint everyone as though
they're somehow discriminatory horrible
just just sub-human scum why because it
makes it okay to treat them inhumanely
right if you believed that you could
somehow manipulate people if you could
go back manipulate people into uh
not liking hitler sway public opinion
you'd probably say hey you know what the
ends justify the means
i can lie about hitler if it means
saving people well they see people who
disagree with them as people who need to
be eliminated and so right here it
doesn't matter that it's not true i'm
just going to put [ __ ] on there it
doesn't matter that i wasn't raped
let's just get this guy expelled and
they're even harming other gay people
you know what's probably happened this
gay guy who made this cake if he's not a
little if he's not a a republican he's
probably a libertarian now he's probably
not on board with the social justice
warrior lgbtq aaai say anything to move
an agenda yeah yeah did you see did you
see who it was he was some liberal
pastor from the liberal pastor from you
know mary the gays church leftist pastor
listen if you want to be a pastor and be
gay sounds like sean king's a pastor
remember that sean king is a pastor yeah
yeah i always forget about that now do
you know what church
i don't know but i know he talked about
a lot about doing mission trips and
things like that i think down in i want
to say haiti or something that's about
all i know
do you think he went down to haiti and
tried to tell him he was black
i bet i want to know that i bet that's
where he tested it out
i'm the american black yeah kind of we
look very different they're very
different very different different
lineage that was like his open mic
testing material out sean king went down
to zambia on mission work and convinced
that's a sketch series right there
so this guy
who's gay makes the cake and he gets
blamed for now here's my issue with it
right this is what really matters
is even with the ted cruz sex scandal
right all not a single one of these
conspiracy theories have been
they've all been proven false or
certainly not proven true time and time
again you can only prove so many things
false okay we have to move on
um
that happens that's front page but when
things are proven false
that's page six
right love wins can you whole foods
can't front page huffpo huffpo salon
these places nowhere to be found
nowhere to be found when it turns out
that no one wrote
hay [ __ ] on a cake
they're nowhere to be found that
happened with me where they you know
they did us a while i've been i've
looked behind the curtain right both in
the cons with conservatives okay
with
the right-wing media and left-wing media
okay you name the network i've done it
you named the the the show i've probably
done it
and this is what they do huffpo did they
said you know i yelled the n-word at
cpac
chris lash it was front page and then
when they had they issued the retraction
but this was front page dead center
trending and then when they found out it
was wrong we were using the word
knickers and even in the video if you go
watch it it's very clear we say knickers
and make a joke about the word knickers
it's a you can do not like the joke but
not lie and say you yell the n word the
retraction is six pages in the damage
has already been done and that's the
same thing that left left us do with
this guy who's been expelled for not
raping somebody or mattress girl if
you've been accused of it the damage is
done and we're at a point for sure if
we're going talking about the rape issue
where there are probably far more men
who's far more male students whose lives
are ruined by the accusation of rape
with no substantiation than there are
actual rapes on campus i know it's hard
to verify but i would be willing to bet
my bottom dollar if we could actually
get into those numbers accurately it is
so much easier like lena dunham to sell
books and falsely accuse someone of rape
by the way
you were reaching in your sister's hooch
looking for rocks
and you're going to complain about it
about fictional rape right so don't
don't don't look about don't look at
this literal child molestation
rape you won't find any shiny rocks up
uh lennon dunham's hooch
was her sister i'm just saying if you're
talking about it i can use that word it
sounds dirtier coming from you
there is no good word for the female
anatomy oh you got schwinxhuang you got
lots of schwans that's for men i know
for men you got lots of options yeah
schmeckel tallywhacker donagher one-eyed
bald man purple helmet warrior you can
go on all days it goes but with like
with women there's no way to there's no
term for it that you would want to use
in front of your mother how do you feel
about bajingo is that an actual term i
heard it on scrubs
for a woman's for a woman yeah
so i don't know there's options we've
gotten way off track here but uh but
it's true anyway tweet me your favorite
word for the female anatomy at s crowder
that you think is appropriate i'm not
talking about like boudoir talk
i'm talking if you have to talk like you
know if i talked with my mom when i got
kicked in the nuts in school i can say
mom this girl kicked me in the nuts
remember when kids would do that in
school because it was like their trend
male privilege whack
um
but if i were a woman how if i were a
little girl how would i go to my dad and
say dad i was kicked in the blank or how
would you talk to a five-year-old girl
if you had to like
non-pervertedly bring that topic i don't
i don't talk to little kids it's a
liability it's a liability you just say
one thing again how often i told this
story before i had a kid who was like a
third cousin
his mom was a drunk his dad was a drug
addict all have done our block and um
he asked me for my game boy
that's no you can't have my game and
i've given him my old game boy by the
way mikhail i had given him my old game
boy but he asked for my new one at this
point it was a game boy color when i
said no he started yelling at the top of
his lungs pedophile
the top of his lungs
i i slapped him i did slap him and i
like i have no i shouldn't have but i
was just like you know pedophile ah
whack oh what did i do and then ask some
decisions to make here's the sad part
that kid's dad didn't have visitation
rights because everyone said he accused
him of being a pedophile and this kid
went on to accuse five more people being
pedophiles because they didn't give them
their tony hawk pro skateboarder 2 video
game my point here to tie it back is the
lgbtq aaip or mattress girl or these
people who falsely claim rape are no
better than five-year-old children who
simply yell and scream to get what they
want the difference is you destroy lives
so if anyone tells you i can't believe
that happened at whole foods
send them the story make sure they know
it's not true mattress girl you need to
make sure they know it's not true you
will be stunned to realize how many
people in your circle of friends sean
king sound like sean king he's not black
not black sean king's not black gosh
you're confused i'm confusing me it's
like black like me only lies louder with
crowder will be back my brain is
okay business time really simple some of
you don't know where to find me
louderwithcrowder.com half a dozen to 10
articles every single day twitter follow
me at s crowder louder with crowder
podcast on itunes soundcloud or any
other podcasting device youtube.com
stephencrowder or you can type in
stevencrowder on facebook and be one of
the million plus fans or join the
mailing list there are so many ways for
you to stay connected you have no excuse
you have no excuse just like you have no
excuse for those roles that are just
cascading over your belt buckle you
should be ashamed unless you're a lady
then you deserve get her a medal
and now for sean king makes excuses
sponsored by twitter and jack dorsey mr
king there have been several allegations
not the least of which is that you are
in fact
not black uh also that you have
plagiarized your recent content also
that you have lied about the
transferring of funds as they relate to
black lives matter
and uh other racially
motivated non-profits yes but you don't
understand something what's that
my mom was a [ __ ] y'all
calling your mom a heart doesn't sound
like a very black thing to do i mean she
was a real filthy [ __ ]
i don't think we're buying it man i'm
telling you that bill's a [ __ ] getting
blacker it's not my fault
that my mom
slept with a man who was white black
she's up with so many people i don't
remember you're really not very good at
this
that's been this week's installment of
sean king makes excuses
ah
that feels good i was just sitting back
into my chair i got my lower back
support right i know that's always
that's when you hit that right in the in
the right mode coming up after the break
we will have gavin mcinnis and we will
play
newest gender pronoun for people who
don't know there are a lot of gender uh
new nouns for genders on tumblr there
are hundreds in case you didn't know
they call them other kins and we are
going to uh see who who knows that deep
dark realm of the world
best okay speaking about equality
here's another story and courtney
kirchhoff wrote about this at the
website of course she's brilliant you
can follow her at uh courtney scoffs
we've talked about this about women on
the front lines right equality great
example we've had karen strawn on um
women shouldn't have gotten the right to
vote
the way they did take that out of
context go ahead uh
the reason most women didn't want to
vote
is because they didn't want the draft
they didn't want the mandatory
requirements that came with voting it
wasn't seen as a basic human right it
was seen as a privilege they didn't want
to perform bucket duty was mandatory
firefighter service so most women were
going well if that's what comes with the
right to vote no no thank you and guys
one of them
won them the right to vote not saying
women shouldn't have the right to vote
today
my point is it was never actually based
on equality
because equality would be okay vote
you're in the draft and you have to
perform firefighter services and if you
don't um you're kicked out and you're
shunned from society uh same thing there
have been laws to protect female spouses
that really don't exist or certainly
aren't enacted to protect male spouses
right abuse actually goes both ways
mothers tend to be more abusive than
fathers people don't realize that
because there isn't a lifetime movie of
the mother pushing the father down the
stairs it happens all the time
so equality we talked about this women
going into the military what at lower
standards well here is something that is
statistically observable what are
statistics said the lady at bucknell
bias all the statistics
in the marines
women can't do pull-ups
the people who are going out there in a
very physical endeavor to defend your
country on the front lines are less
equipped than junior high school boys
let's just be real here
okay
data collection in 2013 finally we have
this up at the website i have it up on
the screen data collection in 2013 found
that 55 of female recruits couldn't meet
the minimum requirement a study of 318
female marines found that women could
complete
on average
1.63 pull-ups
roughly 20 of those marines could only
hit three pull-ups if they use their
lower bodies in a kipping motion
the average for a woman was 1.63
pull-ups
uh listen i know some guys out there
can't do that
you're weak
you are a very weak man if you can't do
two pull-ups okay
and it's something that by the way as a
man doesn't take more than a few weeks
i've i've talked about this um
when it comes to pull-ups you know i
told us about my dad breaking the school
record right yeah you did tell me that
yeah it wasn't a woman who broke up no
hold on i don't know what that what just
happened there um what happened my dad
his my uncle set the school pull-up
record in junior high okay i don't know
if it's it was in detroit somewhere and
uh it was i want to say nine at the time
another guy came in and beat it and it
was i want to say like 11.
so my uncle went down to my dad my dad
was three years younger he said hey
hey hey man you got to restore the
family honor you have to set the pull-up
record this is all true we'll have pop's
crowd around maybe next week to talk
about it it was his own personal hell
for half of that year
in school he said you got you got to
restore the honor i'm gone i'm out of
school now my record got broken so let's
go downstairs i went downstairs and had
a pipe he said let's see how many he
could do my dad
couldn't do one
my uncle wasn't a very nice holder
brother he said you're pathetic
and he just walked up
and my dad every single day went down
and practiced pull-ups all the time it's
what we call greasing the groove just to
get to the point where he was able to do
one he's able to do two and then the day
where it came to set the school record
he went home and he had read that honey
was good energy so he actually just
guzzled a bottle of honey peanut butter
banana sandwiches and guzzled honey and
he went in and he set the school record
with 13. now it doesn't sound like a lot
you're talking about junior high school
so i want to say he was 12 or 13.
and then so he was really he lived in
his own personal hell but he got to that
why because it was hard
he overcame it and he was so scared to
lose right he was terrified and then his
friend actually one of the percheroni
brothers came in and just a little short
italian guy came in the next year and
blew it away with like 21. it wasn't
even close
probably a weight diffraction yeah yeah
exactly the point is he took the
challenge and there was no he didn't say
hey well can we scale this back
took it met it did it
these women who are in the marines so
let's be honest here people say oh that
person's tough man you're in the marines
i wouldn't mess with them unless it's a
chick she can only do 1.6 pull-ups
what do you mean you people i mean women
you mean you i mean women you're weak
they are weak and they shouldn't be in
positions that require any kind of
any kind of physical attributes if they
don't have them so this is where we are
in the military at that point i'm
writing from the article the marine
corps allowed women to choose this is
this is the problem leads into this
choose between pull-ups and the flexed
arm hang as officials developed a new
plan
you know what the new plan was that
developed a new plan it was ah crap
i mean we lowered the pt requirements
this is a joke
what is it what are they not able to do
10 what can we lower to six they can't
do two
what they can't do two yeah we're going
to put them out there with chris kyle
what i know chris cousins i know he's
not a marine the point is that was their
plan was oh crap we don't want gloria
allred to be making a phone call we
can't even do like if we set the minimum
at one pull-up people are going to think
we're being sexist because it's so
embarrassing because women are so
ill-equipped at doing pull-ups let's
just go to the flexed armhang by the way
for those of you who remember back when
they were still the presidential fitness
test
i think was under ronald reagan and
before that pull-ups were a part of it
the flexed armhang was basically like
being put in the stocks it was
embarrassment it was for the boys who
couldn't do a single pull-up and so you
had basically already failed and you
were trying to restore some kind of
honor now listen that's sad
in grade school gym
it shouldn't be happening
when it comes to finding the best of the
best for our service members it's
embarrassing for a 12 year old boy
to say well you want to join the marines
you're going to go you're going to be
fighting isis where they're burning
people alive in cages you're going to be
carrying these packs you're going to be
a part of a squad so your capabilities
actually affect those around you and
their lives depend on you but you can't
even do the pull-ups
let's go with the flexed arm hang
what's next well we can't do push-ups
let's do lady push-ups you know you know
let's just go away with no more push-ups
downward-facing dog
don't ask don't tell is gone downward
facing dog some people are going to be
happy about it while you're down there
let's just make a few new friends
no more pull-ups no more push-ups let's
just do let's just do non-let's do flag
football
and if you don't get the flag that's
okay
at the very least you'll make the marine
cut we'll try and usher you into the
special forces we think that's the fair
thing to do
i i feel like i'm taking crazy pills
gavin mcinnes after this break
you're about to catch the news just in
the nick of time with nick nolte this
last wing was
hard
tax damn
son of a [ __ ] to try and bend you over
and take your
blood sweat and tears
45 of americans don't pay 10
45 percent of americans don't pay taxes
in a rush of victoria
that was news in the nick of time with
nick nolte
hey crowder heads if you're listening to
this on itunes or soundcloud or maybe on
the youtube live stream because that's
the thing now you're missing so much
content at louderwithcrowder.com that's
actually the bulk of what me and my
glorious team not gay giraffe
notwithstanding do on a daily basis
anywhere from 4 to 10 articles a day
with commentary videos gifs images and
it's all free so if you want to be up to
date on the news and entertain just add
louderwithcrowder.com to your rss feed
go check it every day it's free you get
to support the site and then you know
maybe we'll give you for some free stuff
i don't know maybe free college what are
they promising free college health care
i don't know they're probably we'll give
you that just
just bookmark it and we'll give it to
you that's a promise
whoa jared what are you doing shoot
megan with what my ar-15 where'd you get
it ar-15.com oh there's another one
you got him yeah thank god for ar15.com
they have ar-15 and accessories for sale
and the best advice there is on the web
oh no there's another one
you got him yeah with your what ar-15
from where
that's the best place to go and that's
the takeaway because this commercial's
about to stop
c
i'm bernie sanders and i approve this
message
in my travels across this country i hear
too many stories from americans whom the
system has failed
thank you mr sanders i was walking to
work the other day and i fell
and i fell on a peppermint latte at
grande and it went in my mouth
and i drank it
and i did that
for about four more months like every
time i would walk i would chip on the
sidewalk and i would fall on this latte
and it would go in my mouth and now my
doctor says that i have diabetes
and i need you to pay for it
and a bernie sanders presidency
these americans will be heard and bernie
sanders will help them
not good enough america
and now time for gentle insults with dr
ben carson well you see mr blitzer i
understand why one can maybe feel that
way but i think if you take my
comments in context as a neurosurgeon
you'll see that i was looking at it
objectively just like i believe if
someone were to look at your your match
in celebrity jeopardy objectively um it
would not be
dissimilar to an incident of rape in an
alleyway the way that andy richter
handled you on an intellectual level and
i think the sort of demagoguery can can
go either way and i i don't think it's
conducive toward a better dialogue
considering that in the figurative sense
you were sexually assaulted on celebrity
jeopardy
this has been gentle insults with dr ben
carson
okay business time really simple some of
you don't know where to find me
louderwithcrowder.com half a dozen to 10
articles every single day twitter follow
me at s crowder louder with crowder
podcast on itunes soundcloud or any
other podcatching device youtube.com
stevencrowder or you can type in
stevencrowder on facebook and be one of
the million plus fans or join the
mailing list there are so many ways for
you to stay connected you have no excuse
you have no excuse just like you have no
excuse for those roles that are just
cascading over your belt buckle you
should be ashamed unless you're a lady
then you deserve get her a
the medal that i want to do
i just realized something we're back
with our next guest not gay jared didn't
you need to take part here fix this
take part yeah take it apart not gay
jared in the video studio is the only
one wearing clothing our guests you can
see him at rebel media anthony kumia
podcast network you can follow him on
twitter at gavin mcguinness gavin
mcginnis thank you for being on with us
sir
thanks for having me this is you know
it's funny without your shirt off we
have the exact same body we're very
similar we both have the same amount of
chest hair
i i understand now why you were so uh so
so uh promiscuous with the bare look
women women love it and all the all the
ink you have going on you have to i mean
if you have tattoos that's the whole
reason for it right otherwise people
don't get to see it okay we want to lead
with this because this is a game we've
played before you haven't played it and
then afterwards we can talk in the next
segment so we're going to play newest
gender pro this is the game there's a
whole you know there are hundreds of of
genders on tumblr now are you aware of
this that there are hundreds that you
didn't know of i i didn't know there was
the last i tuned into this facebook had
us up to 15. no no no no no no no that's
ancient news you have no idea what
you're talking about he's worse than
dana he's so uneducated he has no idea i
can't you know you know it knows nothing
it's embarrassing for the show
because we present him as an educated
man and he just has no clue okay so
we're actually going to go through them
we have to guess there's going to be a
winner i'm staring at your tits by the
way thank you sorry it was this well
it's we'll say we'll we'll do a check
after all men should work out that much
you end up making little breasts
well it's like as bad as being fat okay
all right let's let's move on it is time
to play jared let's hit it hitting it
ready for it ready for it
okay
quite a lead in there kevin all right
the game you need the rules explained
jared is going to give us an actual
gender it's not actually pronoun gavin
you know you've worked we just needed an
extra syllable it's technically just a
noun
but we cheated so he's going to give us
one and then you and i have to guess
what gender that actually is and then
not aj will give us the actual
definition clear enough
okay all right let's start with here we
go
first one
love gender okay i'll since this is
gavin's first time i'll go this is
somebody who puts no boundaries on their
love and they feel more attached to the
idea of love itself than actual physical
love gavin what do you think love gender
is i'm gonna have to agree with that
they're going to reject the whole notion
of gender and say their focus is on love
which by the way why do you get to say
that gays and straights and other people
and bi
don't buy feel that way
so many of these genders seem to already
be covered
by the five stops
so much hate speech going on so much
hate speech okay not gay jared all right
real real answer real answer real quick
love gender a gender defined by love for
other gendered people who are treated
badly and allow for your own gender as
well
what does that even mean i don't know
if they're not treated badly
can you love someone who yeah can you
love someone who's treated well i guess
so it sounds very scientific no matter
how you cut it okay well okay we need
that we need the the winner
and the contestant with the right answer
was
the guy with the b
i think it means
okay i'll take it i don't think that's
accurate but i'll take it lord hopperdon
gives us okay let's go with another
gender hit us with one jared gender ale
gender ale all right gavin you lead this
one
these are all real by the way these are
actually taken from tumblr right jared
yes
okay
now this could go two ways it could be
beer based and your gender is based on
uh different home brewed ales it's
schwepp's latest hit product
or it could be a play on the word
general
all right they're all saying the same
thing i'm going to go with it is a play
on the word general and gender rail
no i'm going to change my mind mid
description
gender ale
is a gender based on home brewed beer
pumpkin ale uh chocolate ale that kind
of thing okay this guy is a gender alert
okay i am going to go with
i think gender ale is is someone who has
been starved of true love in the current
gender dichotomy so you're so pathetic
and so okay just go lord said
lord zedd judges you what's the actual
definition
gender ale a gender that is hard to
describe mainly associated with plants
herbs and liquids what does that [ __ ]
this is syndicated gavin you're gonna
give jared a whole that doesn't even
that
that doesn't make any sense
so you're in a plant is that like other
kin where you're a different species
these people think that they're plants i
mean it would make sense it's like
botany gender or something all right
well who was closest
you can't have a definition of a thing
until you figured it out yourself you
can't just say plants and i don't know
liquids yeah how are they all related
herbs it sounds like a great soup though
a tree or a tincture uh in any case
mustache
he's not very loyal he's not a loyal
hopper zordon at all gavin you're
winning this um all right let's go next
game yeah
fascia gender
fashion gender okay i'll go with this
first um i'm going to say it is someone
who is fascinated with genders of all
types and
their actual preference is that of
curiosity sounds like something someone
in gender studies would say gavin would
say you
i think a fascia gender is a fascist
gender and this is someone who is chosen
to be male because
they admire hitler
stalin
pol pot
mao these are people who have chosen
male not because of sex but because of
genocide okay
all right let's hear
angry
power ranger monsters
these are reactions way too much control
over the sound give us the winner here
the winner is
faster gender gender experience largely
related to a special interest for all
art for not artistic autistic people
that's
that's serious that's molestation that
is i don't know does that seem like
molestation gavin autistic mean do you
you uh
you think you're autistic and you're not
autistic you're pretending to be
autistic are you pretending to be
autistic or you're attracted to autistic
people i think you go either way i don't
know i don't know
what has autism got to do with gender i
don't understand there's there's male
and female people with autism
i think it's they want to claim it as a
gender that's why i think it's if you're
attracted to them they would consider
that a gender
i don't get i don't understand this at
all this one doesn't make any none of
these make sense how a gender just means
any group i'm attracted to like i like
brunettes am i like a broom gender
only if it's redheads because that is
clearly fetish territory
it's no longer so it's a way to describe
i think they just take a random fetish
and stick gender at the end of the word
that seems to be the trend all right we
have do we have one more chair but let's
hear the winner
i won that you won that one okay i won
that one yeah we have one for you one
for you okay one more and then that's
then we'll then we'll uh let's do one
more let's see
cyclogender okay well i know i think i
know what this is but let's have gavin
have a go at it first okay i'm gonna
guess that this is cyclical they are the
perennials of the gender world and they
are
men for six months of the year and women
for six months of the year or maybe that
doesn't have to define the times it
could be something for four months it
could be three months could be two
months the point is that like a
menstrual cycle this person's gender
changes every let's say a couple
fortnights i'm going to say it's
somebody uh who has an unhealthy sexual
attraction to uh the bill paxton film
twister which is a good film and i
actually would put this under reasonable
category of gender what's the answer
jared
psycho gender a gender identity that
changes with one's menstrual cycles
we actually got one actually this is the
first time
anyone has gotten any correct at any
point all right let's let's announce the
winner the winner the winner
the winner is
before i announce you
and the winner is
before i announce which one of you has
any last-minute cheeses i don't please
there's no cheese for this
all right
i really thought i would if i had cheese
in the physical area uh look at these
pipes when you use foreshortening
shortening we got those tattoos they
probably help accentuate it all right uh
this well we're gonna have that we have
to dance it off okay we have to dance it
off hold on not well
give us a back dance gavin because we're
gonna play the the play off so all right
hit it hit it jared here we go gavin we
want your best thrash
new
i look like gavin took a tumble there
did you take a tumble gavin
yeah your head i had a stroke
you and you and dr ben carson you went
from having your hair slicked back and
then when it came forward you kind of
looked like the ed ed furlong era in
american history x
i'm talking about yeah that's the beauty
of this what you do is if you're going
bald in the back you just keep growing
it and then you get like a razzak for
perms that african-american women use
and you just slick that in and you can
hide all your baldness you're not going
bald in the back are you
yeah there's some problem areas back
there
it really doesn't look that bad
i wouldn't say it going back to the
illusion
well
i'm sorry to hear that gavin no we just
this whole segment just took a downer
i'm married i could have aids and have
no faith i mean i could be a burn victim
and we're good that's magic johnson with
the aids and he's married and uh she
never even caught i don't know how that
works well i know it really isn't that
big of a problem it's actually not real
it's really hard
to give aids to somebody if you're even
if even if you're not necessarily using
a condom it's just one person your wife
depending on the kind of activities you
know you know the real issue with with
aids is if you're a jehovah's witness
and you go off at a tangent with some
weird sect and they tell you that you're
cured and you stop taking the medication
and you die
and you've had hits like purple rain and
you've had songs like uh
um stand back did you guys hear that
prince died actually
good lord jared
that's how we started the show he said
did you hear this he had no idea that
everybody knew this in the world wait i
thought i've been by myself all day did
he have eight
yes did he really
my i i am connected to the gay
underground through my wife who's a [ __ ]
hag and she said that uh her people uh
told her that he had aids and he the
jehovah's witnesses don't tell you not
to take medication but i'm sure within
that there's like you know like the
snake people with christians who think
you can resist snake bites i'm sure
jehovah's witnesses have this well i
know that like christian scientists i
know are a sect that do that and they
don't believe in medicine of any kind i
think he got involved in that kind of
stuff okay they said you're fine dude
god loves you well you talked about this
before all your punk rock friends who
would get cancer and they'd think they
could fix it with creams and they
refused to get you know western medicine
treatment and they were just dropping
like flies and you think this is
polystyrene from x-ray specs died that
way um
uh the girl from the slit that's arie up
she also thought that you should just
take cream and you know they got this
from bob marley because i know ariep's
case and and bob marley
died
dumb melody highly selassie highly
[ __ ]
hold on let it ride
tweet him at gavin mcginnis yeah i agree
with you bob marley i got so much flack
the only great thing about bob marley is
that people who wear it's like the
greatest douchebag meter people who wear
the the bob marley shirts like he let's
be honest
he barely knew more than a few chords he
wrote a couple catchy songs he's the
kind of guy who if you actually sat him
down and tried to discuss you know
theology philosophy
he didn't know what he was talking about
but i don't know how many morons have
one love tattooed and no one is actually
able to explain it to me what do you
mean one love
ah it just means you know like
kendrick lamar just said that he just
said the thing about politics is it all
comes down to one word love and you go
what are you me when i was eight
shut up
all right we have uh we'll keep you out
after this break
and we'll talk more about politics of
the day but that is true i didn't know
that about kendrick lamar we'll have to
go back and talk about that one love
maybe gavin can show us if he has any
tattoo similar ladder with crowder stay
tuned he'll be back
do
we will party hard
glad to be back gavin mckinnis anthony
cumia what's the official website there
gavin
anthonycoomia.com
anthonycoomia.comgavin is filling in for
anthony right now he's hosting how many
hours a day are you hosting
no no no i just did one up that was two
hours oh i do my normal show an hour and
a half a day but he's had jim norton ron
bennington colin quinn a bunch of uh
mentally ill people yes like bobo
um okay the clown
he got the clown no it's bozo oh bozo
good morning get it correct
also the clown is from the 50s yeah i
know a lot of people i'm surprised that
jared even knows this so you were
talking about this we were talking
during the break you've been astounded
you know all aids and christian
scientists aside at the catalog of work
from pr from prince
yeah and this sort of takes sometimes it
takes for them to die before you look
them up like i was listening to the
pogues the other day and i go oh this is
some old irish song that must be 300
years old let me look it up and then
when you see what shane mcgowan wrote
you go holy crap you wrote about 15
major hits yeah taylor swift is the same
and
andrew w.k who you played on the way in
i mean he didn't have it's like these
guys had hits but he played all his own
instruments wrote all his own songs
incredible he had he had at least five
you know who would other two would
really surprise people um paul anka
still yeah why is the political die
police could die no i think he's still
alive
anyway like only a few years ago like
the guy still does things where he's not
in front of he's not in front of the mic
but you'd be amazed and alice cooper a
lot of people don't realize how many
songs yeah how many songs he actually
wrote when you actually look at the hits
and a lot of them were ballads like only
women bleed you and me
and people when you look at it and you
actually look at the best of you're
going oh my god i had no idea and it's
not people thought of this sort of hyper
aggressive thing he really wasn't it was
actually pretty well constructed rock
and roll
prince had nothing compares to you which
was sinead's entire career he had manic
mondays which made the bengals he had uh
when you were mine cindy lopez one of
cindy lauper's biggest hits stand back
stand back stevie nicks
purple rain what sounded like your
greatest hits album right and then his
own created a little red corvette
controversy star starfish and coffee
what is that raspberry muffins and jam
well and compared to bob marley who had
one song
yeah you know there's a certain artist
though like led zeppelin you listen to
them two thousand times and you go i'm
still good let's put it on but with bob
marley it's sort of like eggnog i don't
know if you ever just chugged the hell
at an eggnog right if you you get to a
tipping point where you go i never want
to hear the word egg or nog ever again i
just ruined it and i've listened to a
ton i had a huge bob marley phase as a
young man and i cannot listen to one
chord from that guy trying to think who
i was i became that way with the mars
volta i listened to them a lot as a kid
and i was like you can only kind of like
pink floyd you can only take so much
we're going to do whatever the hell we
want on an album
and it's no longer melodic where i go
all right i've lost my grace period here
um
yeah i guess everyone kind of went
through a bob marley fan and i was
introduced to bob marley you have your
jimi hendrix phase you have your mod
phase
right
you go through all those but there's
something with bob marley where you just
don't want to go back like who who wants
to pull out legend and put it on put the
needle on the vinyl right now nobody
it's kind of like simon garfunkel
simon
i have a little
yeah
it sounds like diarrhea a little bit it
does
i told you we i met our art garfunkel
when he was came into tape arthur and it
was during a phase where we were coached
do not mention paul simon
because and it would just drive him nuts
and we were hearing stories but okay so
we were talking about this curt
schilling is going to be on after you he
got fired from espn for the whole
transgender thing you are mr anti-social
justice warrior right you can't stand it
you one of your biggest videos has been
on the transgender thing
you're also a big trump guy but you're
consistent you like cruz you don't hate
cruz you like trump you like cruz love
cruz loves yes and
exactly so i don't want to paint you in
that box but
where are you right now with the trump
condemning north carolina and uh and and
uh really opposing this law on the trans
bathroom rights is that a screw-up
i am uh on the stephen crowder show
learning that donald trump is against
north carolina's
uh you didn't read this today trans
no oh you caught me um well i wasn't
trying to catch you guys we played the
clip yeah he said he said you know i
think they should trans people should be
able to use whatever bathroom they want
spent a lot of stripe business-wise it
was a bad decision and um you know they
should just leave the laws the way they
are and so my thing is is that it's a pc
yeah spineless caving i think you're
going to see him do this in the general
and it's also a status answer you can't
keep the laws the way they were because
of charlotte right because of charlotte
the reason the state had to step in was
because charlotte was infringing on
private businesses rights and then the
state said no no let's make it you use
the bathroom you're born into and uh and
trump came in and he's he's against it
and he was he was pretty he reiterated
was adamant and i'm not trying to catch
you with it um but that that is what
happened well you caught me and i'm
embarrassed i'm embarrassed for my guy
it's like ann coulter says she goes uh
have you noticed that our guy is insane
he's he's no she said mental
mental he's like a crazed teenager and
he says this stuff and you go
wow are you mental
you are uh that
the whole thing people don't get the
whole day thing they just think they
they accept the left straw man because
they don't want to be known as a bad guy
and this is this is the last greatest
tool like this has nothing to do with
gay they even the fact that they even
lump it in it has nothing to do exactly
it means gay and you go okay i don't
want to be that guy right jeffrey dahmer
when they were doing a documentary with
his life he goes by the way i only ate
black people because they were the
nearest ones around me i i i'm not
racist jeffrey dahmer the cannibal was
concerned about being seen as a racist
right and you go
you know what eating feet that you've
boiled in a pot is way worse but okay
and in this day and age
it's going dick morris territory sorry
gavin to be
remotely conceivably
homophobic
is the apocalypse and you go no no i
just don't want my daughter to be
vulnerable to some creep who goes wait
what's the law okay so i just put a wig
on all right i'm gonna go in yeah and
this has happened this happens in canada
where this has already been legal for a
while oh it happened in seattle going
into women's shelters and abusing women
yeah no you're absolutely fairly scared
of trans guys we're scared of guys
pretending to be trans guys well it's
not even that it's just again it's
infringing on the rights of a vast
majority for for people who are
delusional gavin i didn't want to catch
you with it so we'll go we'll talk about
that another time anthonycoomia.com
well no no no no gavin is very
reasonable and and he always has our
support kevin mcginnis anthony comey dot
com ladder with crowder we'll be back
thank you gavin you're the draining
champion of newest gender pronouns you
need a defender
well you know if you want to catch me
i think you have a trust here
don't fall
oh
i mean
where are you what the [ __ ] let me fall
stephen crowder here hey jared what are
you doing i'm just having trouble
getting through this book that's because
you can't read i know you should have
used freedom project academy freedom
what freedom project academy just go to
fpeusa.org it's a fully accredited
private online school no common core and
absolutely no government funding
whatsoever all the classes are taught
live online kindergarten through high
school with real teachers based around
the country so through freedom project's
classical curriculum students master the
basics like math english history science
alongside some more commonly neglected
courses like logic you're not getting
that in a lot of schools economics
american studies and latin all of which
foster the long-lost art of critical
thinking and create leaders for tomorrow
all classes are recorded to be viewed 24
7 and you can get your very own sneak
peek of any class or professor at
fpeusa.org
open enrollment runs march through july
but classes always fill up fast now do
you have your ged equivalency jared no
is that important i think so i mean you
might want to give him a call that's
freedomprojectacademyfpeusa.org
glad to have that song and no no no
keep it off we're in the third hour now
jared has not put on his shirt
it's hot in here it is hot uh speaking
of which hot what's funny did you this
just happened john kasich the whole nice
guy act i think everyone's catching on
he got so mad he stole the recorder from
reporters what is gavin still on yeah
real quick kevin's
kevin's he's still there
doing he just oh we're not bringing it
back he just won't go away uh he just
won't go away all right well gavin is
still lingering somewhere on the show uh
for those who are watching the live
stream of course listening terrestrially
you do not care
um this has been a not gay jared you got
to let him go at some point he just
won't stop laughing my
my mouse is frozen his apparently is too
so we can't hang but you can't hang up
so he's just always there
look at that anyways um oh you know what
we need to get this video up that's
right you don't have it hillary did you
hear about this this week hillary
pandering to black
again again
it is just so painful bring that video
clip up for people haven't been
following this is just so funny this
week you know hillary clinton has done
that where she puts on the so did barack
obama right putting on the fake black
voice it depends on who he's with real
talk he's going to talk like this and
then he gets in front of black people
and y'all know what i'm talking about
west philadelphia born and raised what
is she barack obama did you start
singing the fresh prince game i like dj
uh uh jazza jeff
man the national treasure um
i don't know that sounds anything barack
obama but just the pandering from the
left and donald trump i just hate fakery
i hate it whether it's hillary clinton
whether it's donald trump whether it's
barack obama whether it's john kasich i
just can't stand it when people fake
things and it's so clear and hillary
clinton i don't know if you can bring up
that video at any point yeah you want to
you know play it yeah okay let's play
this i just saw it
is it newsworthy
not necessarily but it is everything
that's wrong with hillary clinton a
little little in fact by the way not a
single person at bucknell or uh cal poly
when i was there where i've been cal
poly buck now i'm trying to think of
just the college shows recently cal poly
american university bucknell i'll be at
amherst this next week with milo
yiannopoulos and christine hoff summers
not a single young person of the black
lives matter the feminists who show up
who rip down the posters who protest not
a single one of them likes hillary
clinton no they are all bernie sanders
and why
because of this let's roll the clip
marry with you
oh that's right this is this is the
hip-hop redux
so for those of you right now
get it to the point where she's not
this is the problem with whenever you
pull the video clip yeah she's sitting
there talking about hot sauce in her bag
she's like i put hot sauce on everything
i like hot sauce hot sauce hot sauce
can you imagine if i just walked into
the buzzfeed office with their you know
they're no doubt their their their black
lunch table because they segregate the
lunch tables and i walked in and said
hey y'all who's got some watermelon vote
for me for ceo [ __ ]
just danced off you'd have my votes i
would have your vote i have my vote just
some funny hot sauce
i put it on everything really i put it
on fried chicken
i put it on my chitlins this is so fake
maybe she does like hot sauce but then
there was a follow-up on good morning
america didn't see what she was actually
grabbing the bottle of ketchup
was she i don't know she's really funny
hot sauce sauce she's pouring grey pouch
hi no behind for sure well and what's
funny is they followed up and asked her
good morning america so are you a
sriracha person like a tapatio she's
like it's your answer just like kind of
donald trump i love all the verses
she said i love all of them i use all of
them if you're going to ask me what are
your favorite hot sauces okay right away
i'll be okay well sriracha is the
ketchup if i'm using any kind of asian
food pizza that's the basic one and then
we have um
you have dave's insanity if you want to
screw with people and get really hot we
have mad cow hot sauce is one that i
really like i've heard of the bomb the
bomb is well the worst is nuts is uh
there's ass in the tub hot sauce and
there's actually one called ass reaper
and it actually has a little cloak and
skull on top of the hot sauce bottle
this is a true story we used to go to a
place called jack by the way my dad
wanted me to issue a correction he set
the school record in junior high with 16
pull-ups
16 which is pretty impressive regardless
of your age so he did send that to me
sorry pops crowder we used to go to this
place jack astor's was a restaurant in
montreal and it was kind of like a
chili's you know flair and very fun and
this french canadian guy would always
come up and they'd have like hot sauce
with the thing like would you like odd
sauce and so he would come up
and he'd always we'd say we just because
we wanted to hear it we'd say oh what do
you have and he'd run down the list and
he's french and he goes oh we have lots
of hot sauce we have tabasco we have
tabasco chipotle we have louisiana we
have el tapatio we have hassan the tub
and the new one has in space it was
absolutely some of those ass in space
and you would say this is a straight
face
so um these sound like olsen twin movies
yes what was when we got we got that
fantastic hot sauce from the former cop
that was the best
very hot made by a cop on it made by a
cop
it was really good no preservatives
anyway the point is if you're going to
claim you put hot sauce on everything
you should have a couple of answers just
like if you're going to claim that the
bible is your most important book you
should have a couple of verses
you just you should just have a couple
let me just say just say i i like
catching
just just anything
anything throwing anything out there you
know yeah um because that would be the
ketchup answer of hot sauces but go on
john 3 16 john 3 16 of of the bible the
bible yeah uh by the way speaking of
which uh fakery bernie sanders i guess
maybe he finally released his tax
returns we covered it earlier this week
and he didn't release his tax returns so
um
that's it he released his 2014 return
and he's very cheap
he's very cheap surprise if you look of
course leftists do not give
at all and by the way they lied about it
they said that they released their tax
returns to try and leverage this against
hillary clinton saying we'll release our
tax returns if you release your wall
street speeches um they didn't and his
wife has been caught in some fraudulent
scandals for a while now and she's a
lifelong succubus on the government t
working in in the education sector um
and basically supporting her husband's
career campaign i always find that funny
with bernie sanders he's
anti-establishment he has not held a
private job since jimmy carter was
president
maybe reagan if i'm going to say it
without a punchline without exaggerating
he has not
held anything other than taxpayer-funded
employment
for three decades he has he has a little
bit of vested interest yeah a little bit
of a vested interest the guy who you
want to be president is the guy who does
not want the job or need it that's the
ideal scenario is the guy who does not
want the job
and when people say we were talking
about this with dave rubin people said
you know we need money money out of
politics citizens united that's another
point ninety percent of people who say
citizens united they have no idea what
that was about
citizens united it was about citizens
who made an anti-hillary clinton film
and basically we're told you're not
going to be able to make this movie they
tried to this was actual systemic
censorship so it went to the supreme
court and supreme court said no
businesses have the right citizens have
the right to unite and they still
maintain their rights to holding a
political opinion or casting uh
political donations that's what it's
about is there something to fix right
now in the political system as far as
money yes but to just say overturned
citizens united means that you're giving
the government authority to say well we
can't do ladder with crowder
ah you know we don't we don't want uh
gavin mcguinness doing his show ah we
don't want milo to have his podcast
trust me if you believe in freedom of
speech
and you understand what citizens united
is there are flaws in the system
but you need to know don't just walk out
with a few silly buzz words that happens
a lot and so you hear bernie sanders say
it and donald trump says the same thing
we stop citizens united um
it really is someone who's entirely
uneducated tweet me at s crowder what
you think about citizens united what you
think when you do with money and
politics one thing that nobody ever
mentions is uh big unions and here's
something too big unions of course you
know bernie sanders it's a lie he's
taken all kinds of big donations and of
course tons of money from big unions who
have far more money than big oil big
pharma koch brothers uh by the way our
koch brothers check cash to jared so we
live to do this oh that's good it's good
it'll be all next week then still
waiting for the fracking money but it's
coming in the mail and uh
people just they don't acknowledge big
now not only can unions give these huge
contributions look at an example like
goldman sachs right
uh evil republican right-wing wall
street actually no they give a pretty
split amount most of these big banks jp
morgan goldman sachs and on the exact
list in front of me most of them gave
more to obama all big banks are doing is
betting
right and then they hedge their bets but
they're betting on a winner and barack
obama was a winner so they bet on barack
obama and they hedge it they might give
55 45 a really extreme right wing bank
might give 60 uh 60 40. we can hear you
typing not gay jared but unions
99
99 of their contributions go entirely to
democrats now are we supposed to believe
that that 99 of people who are in unions
are democrats you don't find that kind
of a democrat anywhere that kind of a
consistency probably most of them
but certainly not all of them it's also
a lot easier for unions to force these
individual donations through dues that's
something nobody talks about for example
i've had to be in the actors union since
i was 12.
just to be on arthur i had to be in the
union and by the way this is the way
unions set it up they don't want to
protect the worker they want to protect
the unions i was able to get backdoored
in this is a true story total blessing
to get my union card why because i was
able at a young age i wasn't the first
brain in arthur i was able to do the
impression of an impression of the
previous kid
for a few seasons and so they were able
to justify bringing a non-union member
in me and each episode counted as a
credit you need to get six credits
uh to get into the union and uh back
then i think the rules were one film or
a credit and so you wanted to get into
episodic so you could rack up those
credits because guess what you can't
work if you're unless you're in the
union
and you can't be in the union unless you
have the credits so it was a really
really rare occurrence for me to get in
there the actors unions are designed to
protect the actors unions i wouldn't be
surprised if my annual dues that that we
have to pay
um if some of that has gone to hillary
clinton or a bernie fundraiser they can
do that they can tack on a few extra
bucks and you'll never know so not only
do they give giant sums on behalf of the
union
but they are able there's a there's a
lot of if you want to talk corruption
let's talk in michigan unions jimmy
hoffa right
this guy
was buried
my grandfather-in-law saw jimmy hoffa
the day he died when he had breakfast
this is a true story mm-hmm fred quartz
crazy i wish he could tell it but you
know he's dead that's always hard that's
always difficult to do if what if we if
we really want him to tell it we'll just
trot him out in the next election have
him vote hillary clinton
while he's there hey can you tell us the
story oh yeah
hillary clinton democrats get a lot of
dead people who vote for them ah yeah
explains a lot you didn't understand
that were you i tried i was really slow
point is a lot of voter fraud going on
with the left i had a girl in high
school who were talking about that i
don't know who it was who did that in
canada a famous politician and it was a
scandal that he had dead people voting
for him i had a girl remember her name
was sasha she said but mr holm
how could they vote
if they were dead
and i was the one who got kicked out
because i called her a [ __ ]
true story do we have
kurt is on a next segment next segment
next segment next segment we're going to
have kurt schilling exclusive talking
about the espn firing so um and this
whole scandal let's let's stay tuned
kurt schilling ladder with crowder love
you
and now it's time for your dating advice
minute
with bill cosby
now this week's letter comes to me
from russ
from suburban canada that's a real place
to know somebody was thinking of trying
to make up the place
the something
region of the canada with the sugar and
the rain exporters post house from the
coal mines and up in the book
so russell's ass could be
are you gonna you think you can see him
again yeah
this has been your dating advice minute
with bill cosby
i am so glad to have this guest on this
is an exclusive it's the first interview
that he's done uh not gay jared i will
bring them on if you could tweet this
out my twitter just stopped working so
just handle that while we're doing it um
he
scandal top trend all over social media
he works with the fisher house where
they build homes for wounded veterans
and that's he wanted us to plug it
because he's such a nice guy he could
have made it about himself uh kurt
schilling thank you for being here sir
hey what's up guys how are you doing
well i'm glad you sound so so chipper
has this been a tough week or you you
just kind of going with it
i think it's been tougher probably on my
family um
i'm not i don't it's a job not a not a
member of my family and um
you know um
i've got a plan and and you know the sun
came up today it'll come up tomorrow and
go from there well i wish i could say
i'm surprised you know that no no we're
we're past that at this point um how
long have you worked with espn forgive
me i'm not a sportsman honestly i've
worked on and off with them for
i would assume close to seven eight nine
years
um some of the greatest human beings
i've ever known i got to work with the
people i worked with were some amazing
and good and quality people and that's
that's what i'll miss i miss that part
now okay for people who don't know
explain it to them real quick we'll do
two segments with you here to kind of
but explain it so you were you were
relieved of your duties at espn listen
this is this is this is not a one-time
thing i i initially this all started out
when i tweeted
a meme about
muslim extremists and i compared them to
the nazi party and basically saying you
know it's just this quote unquote seven
to ten percent of extremists uh you know
and and then comparing it to the
percentage of nazis uh in the in in
germany right the nazi party and talking
and basically saying you know how did
that work out and then i said something
to the point when you do the math it's
pretty staggering well
i was on a flight to the little league
world series and i was immediately told
to get on a plane and go home and they
put out a
a statement almost me disavowing
themselves of the tweet
and my first response was
okay
i don't know
what are you disavowing what what and
and then i quickly realized that
everybody that went
batshit crazy
did so because they took the word
extremist out of the post right
which if you do that it's an incredibly
racist thing
which is why i did it it was the only
word that mattered in the tweet actually
well yeah they don't care about that so
that was your first offense that was but
basically to me the first thing that
that told me was my employer is not only
like throwing under the bus but they're
calling me a racist right
well and it's also it's also not even if
you remove extremists it's not racist
you have a problem with an ideology and
a religion islam is not no i have a
problem with extremists right muslims i
mean my guy worked with some sure i
don't
nobody has a problem with people that
are that are uh you know everyday
muslims people have problems extremists
i don't care if they were white
extremists black extremists but they're
muslim extremists
and their faith tells them to kill
anyone not of their faith and this is
very much like nazi germany well and
then muhammad the point is you know
because you can get into territory with
muslims i want to get to the more recent
one but muhammad was a terrorist
muhammad himself was a terrorist that's
how islam spread around the world
through war yeah conquered exactly it's
spread by the sword um right speaking of
sorts so anyway so anyway yeah so going
forward then i made a comment about
hillary clinton and that comment was
basically if she's guilty she or i
thought based on the evidence she's not
only is she guilty but she's so guilty
she should be under the jail people took
that to me i wanted her killed which was
wrong and they got all pissed about that
too
and then they sent out the memo um that
everybody gets and it was the same memo
we had gotten before but
i was
i feel like and i'd have to look back
but i was called out for the things that
i had said
while there were things being said on
the other on many other shows
that were very liberal very progressive
uh racist uh i mean stephen a smith does
it pretty much daily sure and and so
you know i was kind of curious but then
this last one was yeah so we have this
up on the screen not good jared the meme
so i i i responded to a tweet or to a
facebook post that someone else had made
now there's a couple things to know
about this
i responded to it my response was
basically listen men's rooms were
clearly made for guys people that stand
up to go pee in women's room not you
know i use words i might not should use
anyway
that turned out to be transphobic right
now the other piece to know about this
is i made this comment on and shared
this post on and i don't i'm not saying
my private facebook page but the only
people that could see the the the post
on my page and the comment were my
friends quote unquote friends people who
were friended me on facebook so it
wasn't public
but even then you know even if you
didn't because you understand and you
are being tactful because you work with
espn but even then um suggesting that if
you have a penis that you should use the
men's room should not be something seen
as so hateful and bigoted that you lose
your job i said my point was what the
hell was a urinal made for
i mean
and i was being i wasn't really being
procedure when i said it but it's like
listen
men's rooms were made for people to go
to the bathroom standing up and women's
rooms were not if they weren't then
there would just be one bathroom
everybody would use right
but but just again now i became
transphobic well that's the new term
right because they have they have the
same sex marriage they have same-sex
marriage and that was pushed through the
supreme court and it's over now and
they've accelerated right away like okay
well now now everyone's transphobic
that's and they just tack it on to the
gay thing too like you see with north
carolina it has nothing to do with gay
here's the problem that that first of
all nothing i said was transphobic
number one
i
i
when i ran the video company that went
so
poorly at the end
i had
multiple transgender employees who were
some of the best i had people that i
worked with my son my one of my youngest
sons is a member of the lgbt club in
high school he helped he helped run it
let me ask you something real quick
transgender employees how do they fill
out that application and did they did
they i don't know never cared don't care
but i just want to know if they thought
they were pulling the wool over over a
curtain that's the thing here's the
thing that i've come to realize
the reason people get pissed is because
we don't make it as big a deal as they
want it to be right i don't care i don't
care what you wear i don't care who you
sleep with as long as it's not my wife i
don't care what color what rate i don't
care about that stuff i've never cared
about that stuff and i'm old enough that
if i had those ghosts in my closet
they'd be out
right
and plus i
last i checked and for the most part
people i know if you're racist you're
not afraid to admit it
no
they're proud of
yeah it's definitely not something
that's that you know that that's why
they try and act because there's a
secret remember when they used to say
well if you use the word socialist it's
code for the n word for barack obama and
now you have bernie sanders who just
says i'm a socialist i was like no we
don't believe the n word
yeah we have our little we have it's
like a little orphanage secret decoder
pen we go okay socialist that lines up
with the other one that's the thing see
i don't i don't have one and i don't
care and and here's here's why we have
to go to a break and i'll get you one in
the mail and we'll have you back uh to
talk about this uh kurt schilling
nice guy man got the short of the stick
deserves better lottery crowd will be
back with him stay tuned
oh man i need to drop a dude
but today i'm still just a bill
hey if you're listening to or watching
this podcast there's a strong chance
that you are not yet following me on
twitter at s
crowder where i'm tweeting all day long
i'm ticking off the social justice
warriors you should see the amount of
hate i get on there far far far worse
than any fat sports illustrated model or
black lives matter charlatan so listen
it's free you get to be entertained and
you can chime in also if you're
following me on twitter you can send me
your tweets and maybe you'll be lucky
enough and i mean lucky enough because i
have a lot of followers okay that they
call me the follower machine
to have your tweet to me or not gay
jared included in our rockinest tweet of
the week so follow me on twitter at s
crowder if not
i don't want to say i have sights on
your mother but
oh she's dead
you're just saying that because i made a
mom joke no she's really dead well you
kind of walked into it
all right glad sorry i had to do those
commercial breaks with our evil
corporate overlords but this man's a pro
he knows the business kurt schilling i
would give his twitter handle but it's
so hard it's hard to say so just type in
kurt schilling and he shows up he's
verified curt thanks for staying with us
brother
what's up okay well what's up there's so
you were talking about a lot a lot of
things the the under the prison hillary
clinton was that a breaking bad
reference someone mentioned that on
twitter yeah oh okay great program a
little known fact overwhelmingly
one of the greatest ever it is really
good i like sons of anarchy first when
it came out and then it got to the point
was like oh i don't know how much i can
stay with this and then yeah my wife was
in the suns and then my west wing is
still my favorite ever yeah um and then
sons is pretty good but breaking bad was
oh my god yeah it's as good as it gets
and my friend used to actually write
back and forth physically with brian
cranston and uh a little he was actually
thinking about becoming a priest at one
point just really really no idea he was
that talented really
well the baseball commercial that he did
was i don't know if you saw that what he
was doing that he did the one-man
baseball show like a commercial on the
mlb network or something it was one of
the funniest things i've ever seen in my
life well i i knew you know malcolm in
the middle i thought it was it was an
incredibly underrated program and
largely because of him if he was in the
scene everyone elevated their game and
comedically he was just that people
don't realize what an influential show
malcolm in the middle was moving toward
that single camera sitcom um in the
united states and i'm always i'm always
blown away by
how good an actor has to be to make you
hate their character this is true
you know you start out thinking wow what
he's doing is like come on how can you
be mad at him he's trying to and then by
the end it's like what a piece of track
like
it ended perfect speaking of hate there
are a couple guys i want to dive much
more horrible deaths this isn't right
this is true but not hillary clinton we
want to clarify speaking of hate so
what's been what was it what was the
process like where you know you no
longer work at espn how did they let you
know
um you said you've met good
did it create some some factions did you
feel thrown under the bus and then what
was the public reaction well i mean i i
i did feel i've been i feel kind of from
a top level perspective thrown on the
bus for for quite a while but that makes
me sound like a victim and i'm not
my biggest issue
was
that they made me drive two hours
yesterday to meet with somebody in hr
that they could have just called me
like
you know i drove down there i've done
many of those meetings yes wow well i i
found some but i'm like you know i'm
talking to him and he goes well we're
gonna have a meeting and he'll probably
get a call i'm like
seriously what i mean what's the hold up
i mean you have
you basically cornered yourself into not
having an option
the funny thing is i want to say this
about your meme your meme wasn't even uh
anti-trans for people who didn't we
brought it up earlier they can go search
on twitter what it was it was saying if
you have a different opinion you are
accused of being a hateful transphobic
bigot it was a commentary on the social
justice warrior left so my question is
is it basically just an unwritten espn
policy where you have to have
that opinion on the lgbtq aaip silent f
otherwise you're not welcome there yeah
but it's not that's not a secret i mean
again if you listen to the commentary
look right and i i hate to say it like
this because i'm not lumping everybody
together because again i had some
amazing people i got to work with but
but i here's here's what i might the
analogy i use with a couple of the
employees there that i was spoken with i
said listen if i'd come out yesterday
and said
transgender people are the greatest
people in the world and if you don't
agree you're a son of a [ __ ] they would
have said listen please don't use that
language on the air that would have been
it
that would've
said that right but but
and listen the other people screaming
about you know first amendment this and
first the first amendment doesn't apply
here this is not about i have freedom of
speech but when you work for other
people you have consequences if you say
things that they don't get
get along with but my problem is i don't
believe
you can have a double standard i don't
think it's legal to
to allow one racist opinion and not
allow another if you don't agree with it
right well well and also in your defense
because i know there's nothing that you
said was racist at all or anything along
those lines and that's you know what i
tried to talk to people i was talking to
some people and i spoke to somebody that
was that is actually transgender and i
said listen we were talking about how
this all came to be and i said you know
to be very clear if you want more people
to be either sympathetic or open to
hearing about your cause then you've got
to at least attempt to be taller the
tolerant people you want everyone else
to be no and i will say regardless of
anecdotally if you have trans friends
we've had a lot on the show um there
were plenty of stops on this logic bus
have said we could have pulled the lever
they didn't want gender-neutral
bathrooms a third bathroom that's a
perfect solution but they believe that's
the movement the gestapo the trans-stopo
believe it's discriminatory to have a
third bathroom where it's like okay this
is all bets are off that way everyone's
comfortable that wasn't enough has
nothing to do with plumbing finances no
no exactly
one of the questions i've got to ask
though is
when did people believe
that the world was supposed to conform
around them
instead of
conforming to the world you live in or
working shaping yourself to the world
you live in people now expect the world
to shape itself for you and i i don't
that's not that's not how it works well
that's how they're trying to make it
work right yeah i mean let's talk you
know gay people two percent of
earth obviously there's nothing wrong
love gay people have them on the program
disagree with them we just said dave
rubin on this show super gay lovely
gentleman uh then you're getting to
trans people you're you're a single
percentage point of a single percent
point and many of those people aren't at
the front lines fighting for this social
justice bathroom issue you are talking
such a small percentage of people who
have so much control and can get people
like you
fired simply for disagreeing that's true
and this is one of the things this is
how we've gotten to where we are we've
allowed the vocal minority to shut up
everyone else right and now it drives
every all of our political agendas
here's the thing
i don't
care
if there was a transgender march down my
street to have transgender bathrooms i
wouldn't go out and watch it and i
wouldn't care that they were having it
no i i want homeless veterans to have
homes i want orphaned and abused kids to
have homes i want the homeless problem
in this country so there are so many
other things that are actually
legitimately scary right and dangerous
like i don't know isis
but by the way little known fact isis
not huge supporters of the lgbtq
community but that's the other piece
right i mean bruce springsteen might you
know wow you know you're awesome you
boycott north carolina so i'm assuming
all your stops in italy are now canceled
because same-sex marriage is illegal in
italy right or brian adams was in egypt
performing right no in the middle east
you get beheaded or executed or thrown
off a roof from 30 stories if you're if
you're gay if you're a woman who loses
your your uh scarf
or if you're not a a member of the of
the faith well you know what that might
be more convenient for trans men because
all they need to do in those countries
is toss on the headdress and no one's
you know what again
people joke about it and it's but the
problem is that that
that the world people pick and choose
strategically right exactly what they
want and like you said the problem is
listen it's not only minorities
obviously that's why we're a
representative
republican not a democracy but like
donald trump came out today we were
really disappointed he said oh they
should leave the laws the way they are
well we're at a point you can't because
charlotte decided to step in and so the
state had to say no no no you can't do
this use the bathroom you were born with
you can't come in and in front of you
the other thing i said
i'll tell you there here was this was
the media to a tee today i saw i was
tagged in a post that somebody posted
from a transgender website that said
something to the effect of cursed
chilling post horrible transphobic meme
calls transgender people pathetic
and i s i'm waiting i'm like wow you
never did that well i'm thinking wait
wait what did i
at the bottom of the response i had said
that we need our government to step in
and make these laws now is pathetic
right
yeah well uh i do think that if you if
you need to be cradled in a safe space
because you can't use the ladies room
when you have a pecker i would say that
person is pathetic and i don't think all
trans people are that here's the thing
like
i don't ha everybody's talking about oh
my god you know people are going to get
raped in women's bathrooms it's the
issue is not this no it's not what's
going to happen and you can sure it's
already happened but it's going to
happen one time in a big way
somebody is going to get molested in a
women's room and it's going to be a
child and some scumbag pervert child
molester is going to go to jail and the
transgender community is going to be in
a place they never ever wanted to be
you know they're going to have to be
defending their right to use a bathroom
which opens up the door
for
you know what this is just like the
whole like uh
anti-police thing right right they're
our most violent year ever in history
for baltimore when they started building
they're amazing men they're amazing men
and women who put their lives online
there are bad eggs and they're and they
should be suffer the worst penalty ever
right but that's not representative of
the force
like pedophiles are representative of
transgenders and transgenders are
pedophiles but there are people that
will manipulate this law to their
advantage and someone is going to get
hurt right yeah no i i think you're
absolutely right and i don't even think
that's necessary because well what if
what if it doesn't happen it doesn't
even matter because again most women are
immensely uncomfortable with it as they
should they go what about men yeah you
and i and nakajid probably not
uncomfortable in a men's room why
because women aren't naturally sexually
predatory the way men are it's the way
we're wired every single boy's fantasy
is to go into the girls i'm going to ask
you though
why why tell us i don't care
i don't give a [ __ ] what what if you
come into the men's room and you're
standing there taking a piss i don't
care if you go into the stall i don't
why do i have to know you're not a real
uh a born man i don't care well
the issue is a lot of women did care and
felt uncomfortable and so cities enacted
laws absolutely absolutely but here's
the other piece all right think about
the year the world two years ago that we
lived in right if bruce jenner had
happened and no one had ever known
today would we would the world be any
different
yes ken would have given the courage
what was the sentiment there like we did
the whole we did the whole fake olympics
with caitlyn jenner winning the
commentary caitlyn jenner if we believe
this is a new person is separate from
bruce caitlyn jenner has precisely
as many athletic accomplishments as not
gay jared zero right
and an award happening
behind the scenes at espn where even
even the the far left would like yeah
okay this is kind of ridiculous here's
the thing and it was you know it was
taboo to speak of right in any way but
but a positive so when no one spoke
about it and you know and that was it
but except you
i i here's the i don't who cares
honestly who's who cares and why would
you care if you care that's fine you can
go have your discussion and and the
other piece i tried to make these people
understand that i was speaking with
an opinion and a belief are two very
different things right this is an
opinion my opinion is malleable it's all
all of my opinions are
most peoples are my belief that jesus
was the son of god and that my you know
and my family those things those are
unshakable right
well right away
you're given far less leeway the second
you make no right but but if i'm a
racist that's a that's a fundamental
belief of mine that one race is superior
to another right if i'm if i'm
homophobic
my belief my foundational belief is that
gay men aren't worthy of the same life
i'm worthy none of those things are true
no but people but but here but think
about this
and this was to me the thing that that
really got to me when people are calling
you things that you could not even come
close to being
you know somewhere the wiring screwed up
no it's it comes from top down it is at
that point it is closed no you're right
are you right but listen if i if i would
if i said the n word in my life my dad
would come out of the grave and pull my
heart through my chest and kill me right
i i don't i've never in my life judged
somebody on anything other than how they
treated me and i've had preconceived
notions of people like yeah that guy's a
douche and then i had to play with a guy
and he's like the greatest teammate i've
ever had i mean i learned that enough
times to know right but when people are
calling you a racist and you you're
what's been the public reaction is my
question because we can get into the
back rooms and i appreciate you letting
us know i i think it's been exactly what
i listen i expected it when the when the
the muslim thing came out it was the
same thing like they they knee jerk
reacted and then about two days later
they everybo
i'm going in circles but
this is like 9 11 right and 9 11
everybody was cut this country's the
grand let's go kick everybody's ass
right and then the really loud folks
they die out in about six months right
this is no different all these people
screaming and yelling in 48 hours
they're going to be moving on to
something else because they i got fired
and they're all happy well i think this
though i think you've had to be sitting
there going wait i think i think you got
more support than espn expected
oh i don't know absolutely yeah i don't
think i think they're pushing way too
hard right now too fast and this may
have a rebound effect because if you
look if you look at social media it
wasn't even split a majority of people
thought that this was pretty ridiculous
and i i think it shows that i'm touching
even though a majority of people who did
didn't agree with the thing i posted
were saying the same like right this is
ridiculous
we have to go mr schilling thank you so
much and i know you're going to start
going on this tour and everyone's going
to want a piece of you if there's ever
anything we can do let us know but thank
you for stopping by and uh man i i
appreciate that you're willing to stand
in the pocket i appreciate i'm gonna i'm
gonna be on breitbart tomorrow morning
so that should be enjoyable that should
be a lot of fun curt schilling thank you
sir we must go lotto with crowder stay
tuned as we wrap it up
this week in not gay jared's diet habits
is that doritos now no well i mean yeah
but the cool thing seriously though
i'm concerned about you there's no way
you can be healthy you're sick all the
time you're coughing don't worry don't
worry about it i took um i took one of
those things
you took a vitamin a vitamin d doesn't
make up for everything you talked about
i took one of those um this earlier
today just just this morning
a vitamin doesn't it's it's to
supplement no no no
eminem
stay tuned for more of not gay jared's
diet habits
hey crowderheads if you're listening to
this on itunes or soundcloud or maybe on
the youtube live stream because that's a
thing now you're missing so much content
at louderwithcrowder.com that's actually
the bulk of what me and my glorious team
not gay jared notwithstanding do on a
daily basis anywhere from four to ten
articles a day with commentary videos
gifs images and it's all free so if you
want to be up to date on the news and
entertain just add louder with
crowder.com to your rss feed go check it
every day it's free you get to support
the site and then you know maybe we'll
give you for some free stuff i don't
know maybe free college what are they
promising free college health care i
don't know they probably will give you
that just
just bookmark it and we'll give it to
you that's a promise
um
and that sound
that sound that original track means
that it is the end to our program
really glad all the guests who came on
incredibly grateful mr uh kurt schilling
um our first the first program he did i
have no i listen we don't deserve that
we really don't so we did nothing too we
have no business getting these exclusive
scoops every now and then we just have
people who either follow or fans and and
uh
i don't know we we have the ability to
get to it first
um
some people apparently i guess there was
some kind of a live mic thing jared that
people were talking about so fix that uh
this is the last segment here so i
wanted to sort of follow on what on what
kurt was talking about because i i know
he has to be careful and not that he
pulls any punches but there are legal
ramifications right if he says something
kind of like when ben shapiro was on the
michelle field situation
anything you use in public can be used
legally and that's why it's important
for example when you have politicians
who mis
misuse the terms where they they
consider them interchangeable like
battery and assault if you use the wrong
one or someone committed a misdemeanor
and you say felony well now you're on
the hook for slander so i wanted to to
give if you come on a program you're
really nice and respectable then you
play spot the training afterwards you
have nothing to do with it but
it doesn't matter it happens it still
happened and then they're going to show
the gif of me and gavin you know uh
touching the areolas and then they're
like are you running for president sir
and this was the program on which you uh
you paid a visit so i think next week we
might actually have libertarian
candidate austin peterson
if i'm correct and then was there there
was someone else who were talking about
talking talking talking talking who was
it
oh uh it might be well it might be um
might be nick apollo i think next week
we're not entirely sure but austin
peterson a few other guests uh coming on
so we're we're always grateful listen
the common thread here with with what
kurt was talking about
is
he was quieted he was silenced he was
fired for being transphobic racist
homophobic that's what happens on campus
you know the more i perform on campus
and i hate it i honestly i'm looking
forward to this being over the tours um
we're going to do a few more dates here
go to louderwithcrowder.com to see them
through the spring then we'll take it
off in summer and then fall just
colleges really suck they really suck
now because you show up and people
protest and for conservative
provocateurs it's fun because you
videotape it and they show up and
they're mad when you just want to do
stand up it gets to the point where it's
almost impossible you know and it's it's
really no longer fun to do
but again when i spoke with these kids
and it's the same exact thing that's
happening with curt schilling it's the
same thing that's happened on campus
with a guy being expelled for not raping
somebody it's the same thing that
happened with whole foods
all of these tactics and techniques
they were used entirely from the left
now oh you're just using the left right
divide man yes
and i don't shy away from it and it's
entirely appropriate
you do not see this coming from
conservatives you don't see this coming
from the right
certainly not in record numbers this way
if they get mad at something that
someone said
they don't try and get that person to
lose their job maybe now with some
factions of the right wing i don't know
maybe it happens but certainly not
conservatives who i've worked with my
entire life
on campus they try and ban speakers
racist sexist homophobic right so what's
their solution don't let them speak
kurt schilling put out a meme on his
private facebook page where he basically
thinks hey if you were born a man
specifically if you don't go through
with the surgery you're probably still a
man and the meme was was pointing out
this idea that if you say that you're
hateful and bigoted he didn't even
necessarily say that he the meme was
about even saying that it's considered
hateful and bigoted and what do they do
is it putting out that meme as hateful
and bigoted i just just set him right up
right sort of
so what's the solution
fire him
make sure he doesn't get to speak
now every time i go to college campus
these these speaking engagements they're
open and liberals come in
you know what conservatives on campus
never do
they never try and ban people
it doesn't happen
uh you don't see it with college
republicans you don't see them wanting
to erase chalk and demanding safe spaces
you may think they're wrong again left
and right man yes left and right the
right does not try to constantly their
go-to is not silence voices of
opposition by defaming the person before
the argument even begins you counter bad
speech with more speech
dave rubin we were talking about he was
on our program i was on his program this
week he he's never received more hate
mail
dave i like dave rubin
we're actually we've become friends and
we disagree on nearly everything
but we're willing to have that idea
guess what no one on this program no one
who watches it ever complains and we
have dave ruben on
it doesn't happen
you'll see people say oh you know they
might make a joke but say he sees he's
so far left he's wrong about everything
he has his head up his rear i'm glad he
comes on the show
same thing when we have left a son
whether it's or people who lean more to
the left like like sargon or dl hugh lee
can't think of anyone we've had on that
people had some visceral nasty reactions
doesn't happen
flock their page and spam them with hate
online people really hate the young
turks but that's because they do that
without with us that's all they do is
paint everyone is racist so people are
tired of it but you have to look at this
and i know you it's easy to be a fence
sitter and say well you know it's it's
not left to right people are yes
everyone is an individual but if you
look at what's happening on campus if
you look at what's happening in the
media if you look at what's happening in
the government there's consistently one
side that always if they can do it first
if they can drop this nuke first they
will
silence it before the dialogue begins
that's why they try and ban me on campus
it's why well i didn't do it we have
bomb threats
at cal poly
now i don't go out there and put it on a
website and make a big deal out of it
why because i just want to do stand up
and then after the fact we can talk
about it you know a lot of people think
this press is good press but when you've
actually had security problems
talking about the islam we actually
underplay it
conservatives don't do that
so yeah it does matter to see the world
isms are okay
i don't believe in any ideology man it's
always fluid well you can also you can
also be blinded by that
because at a certain point
if you refuse to notice consistencies
there is nothing different nothing
different about what's happening with
curt schilling at espn
and what happened at whole foods or on
campus like bucknell where i was it's
the exact same thing it is the tactic of
the left and here's what i will say you
should listen to people
you should always have a dialogue if you
can but if someone immediately goes to a
racist card or tells you that someone's
a racist or a transphobe or a homophobe
their opinion should immediately be met
with skeptic skepticism and the first
thing you need to do is stop them and
whoa you say racist
justify that well hold on you say gay
rationalize it because i tell you what
when i sit there and i do these shows on
campus for two hours some have been two
and a half they're never able to
they're never able to rationalize it
they're never able to make that position
tenable just like they won't against
curt schilling they'll just say he's a
racist or a transphobe someone says that
you should immediately put them on your
radar if someone you should be skeptical
louder with crowder see you next week
you